so Joe Biden got caught in a very
serious quid pro quo Democrats are
threatening to pull military aid from
Saudi Arabia because Saudi Arabia won't
help them win the midterms which is um
well I can't say I'm surprised they
claimed that Donald Trump was doing all
of this which he wasn't
Ukraine claimed there was no quid pro
quo and now the gist of the story is
that the Democrats went to Saudi Arabia
and said do not halt oil production
for one month
just one month and then after that do
whatever you want why just one month is
there something big happening in the
next 25 days so of course they'll deny
it but now you have Democratic members
of Congress that are putting forward
legislation to basically poll aid from
Saudi Arabia Biden is threatening Saudi
Arabia saying we're going to be looking
at everything we can this is them
basically saying quid pro quo you better
give us what we want help us win or else
let's see how much the mainstream media
actually carries this story surprisingly
CNBC is picking it up so we'll talk
about that plus oh I love this I just
want to mention this it's kind of a
passive story but Snopes acknowledging
True Gas was under two dollars during
Donald Trump we've also got on the
ballot in Oregon a a it's a provision
inching towards secession from Oregon
that's it's eastern Oregon into greater
Idaho which is very very interesting and
oh I love this one so much AOC gets
heckled by what appears to be
progressives for supporting war in
Ukraine and funding the azov Battalion
so you earned it AOC before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member by
clicking that beautiful join us button
when you sign up we default the payment
through parallel economy co-founded by
Dan bongino I'm a big fan he's doing a
lot of tremendous work helping push back
against censorship
all of our infrastructure is through
rumble's Cloud infrastructure as a
member you aren't just getting access to
the exclusive uncensored members shows
we'll have one up for you tonight you're
also helping these companies like Rumble
and parallel economy as well as Tim cast
you're helping us build that that space
in the long run what I really hope
happens is we're just one customer of
parallel economy I hope that more and
more businesses start using them as
their payment processor so we can give a
big Fu to the woke corporations that are
debanking people
so go to timcast.com sign up but don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share this
video be the notification we're about a
month out people are saying YouTube's no
longer sending out notifications for the
show they're struck here's the crazy
thing people are saying it won't even
appear on the channel it won't even
appear on YouTube and they have to try
and find it it's hard for them to find
some are like they got to get someone to
send them the URL yeah dirty games so if
you are listening take the URL and share
it so that people who can't find it will
be able to and new people might find out
about it joining us today to talk about
all of this and more is Jim antelope
good to be here thanks for having me who
are you I'm politics editor of
Washington examiner author of devouring
Freedom can big government ever be
stopped it was more than one page oh
okay I hope the answer to that question
is no I mean I mean it's yes not no it
can't be was it was yes I don't know if
I rewrote it now I might be a little
more skeptical but yeah I actually think
you know as crazy as things are getting
I I I'm very optimistic about everything
that's happening because it's getting
crazy because they're getting desperate
you know the thrashing around all
violently and crazy but their ratings
are in the gutter people aren't paying
attention anymore they're getting
exposed so thanks for hanging out man
should be up should should be a blast we
also got the T-shirt vendor himself hey
guys my name is we are change.org today
I'm wearing uh my friends Johnny's
Hurley's shirt that reads no master no
slave Johnny was a hero that actually
stopped the mass shooting in 201
the police actually took him out it's a
crazy story I did a video about this in
Arvada Colorado that was just released
on my YouTube channel youtube.com
forward slash we are change and there's
info where you could actually get this
shirt where the profits are going to be
going to the Johnny Hurley foundation so
check it out on my YouTube page thanks
hi everyone Ian Crossland here from Ian
crossland.net
um we're in one of my favorite shirts
Tim actually got me this as a gift one
day thanks again you know it's funny
because
we'll go out I'll go to the mall or go
to some weird store and I'll see
something and I'm like that's Ian you
know like I saw that hoodie and I was
like that's an Ian hoodie it really it I
become more the hoodie as I've had it
longer uh we're secretly behind the
scenes shaping Ian's character that I'm
realizing we went to we went to Cooper
Rock in West Virginia and they have a
barrel full of rocks you buy by the
ounce I've got a bunch of them here in
front of me Ian likes Rockets so I
filled up a little bag and I bought it
it was like five bucks I massaged this
Ruby throughout the show from time to
time uh and I'll let you guys know if
you want to follow me on mines I'll let
you know where I got or what company
made this because people have been
asking me if you want to get one for
yourself what's happening search hey
guys I'm here again uh I am reading the
comments if you guys saw me yesterday or
in the evening usually just until the
night is up until I feel like going to
sleep so I'll see you guys again there's
tonight later on uh take it away sir
just pressing the buttons all right
here's the first store we got this from
timcast.com Biden wanted OPEC OPEC plus
Cuts delayed until after the midterms
Saudi Arabia says Biden now faces Alex
locations of quid pro quo similar to
alleged deal that was the basis for
impeaching former president Donald Trump
this is from Hans monk he says this is
extremely damning in Trump's case the
quote victim of the quid pro quo
zielinski emphatically denied there was
any suggestion of quid pro quo in
Biden's case the victim is formally
accusing the US of just that quick and
simple just to the story
Biden Administration goes to Saudi
Arabia and says we know you're going to
start cutting the production of oil
wait one month
just one month
that's uh uh conveniently just after the
midterms
Saudi Arabia said no we're not going to
do that and it's we're not going to do
it for economic reasons now I was
initially reported that they were siding
with Russia that's one way you can frame
it and I think the media jumped at that
because it kind of absolves the
Democrats of any kind of a
responsibility that it was really about
just American interests and stopping the
war now we learned
it was for one month if the Democrats
goal was really to help the American
people with lower gas prices and stop
the war with Russia to stop Russia being
able to finance their War they wouldn't
have said halt uh halter keep production
up for one extra month they would have
said do not cut your production do not
let Russia do this instead it was
obvious they wanted a political
Advantage a quid pro quo and when they
didn't get it what we see now are the
Democrats threatening Saudi Arabia with
pulling military aid and other support
you know if they really wanted to help
they would allow domestic energy
exploration and production they're not
doing that in the name of green energy
we're shipping in oil from Saudi Arabia
all in the name of fighting climate
change which is absolutely absurd how
many yemenis children had to die for the
U.S Petro dollar and now we're at a
situation with a Saudi Empire is just
slapping Joe Biden back and forth and if
you remember just a couple weeks ago Joe
Biden had his Landmark trip to Saudi
Arabia where he was going to turn on the
faucet to oil and after that trip the
Biden Administration literally released
the statement saying Saudi Arabia is on
board they're going to help us lower gas
prices Saudi Arabia came out and said no
Joe's lying here and now we're finding
out according to Saudi Arabia which is
absolutely just such a big bombshell
when it comes to Saudi Arabia saying
this on the world stage because of the
Petro dollar because of Yemen because of
how connected the United States was
especially when it came to financing
radical jihadists all throughout the
Middle East with Saudi Arabia you see
the decoupling of Saudi Arabia and
America that to me is the biggest story
here which will have huge ramifications
on the financial economy not just with
gas prices but with the purchasing power
of the US dollar so uh world war three
is that what's happening no uh just uh
incompetent crazy leadership and this is
not the first time we had a quid pro Joe
which I think it should be changed to
after this latest Revelation you know
and Biden has a history of of this yeah
he did this in 2015 especially when it
came to the prosecutor in Ukraine
looking into brisma oil and his son's
connections to this he bragged with the
president of the Council on Foreign
Relations about firing him while holding
Aid money hostage to that particular
country so again this is nothing new
this is a quid pro Joe but this was done
in such Plain Sight other than the
one-month aspect of it I mean he went
hat in hand over to Saudi Arabia very
publicly he denied that he was going hat
in hand he that it was about oil it was
about the war effort Russia it was about
the environment climate change all of
these other things that he was going to
go over there and fist bump with people
he had said on the campaign Trail he was
going to make a pariah that he was going
to isolate because of their role in
Jamal khashoggi's death a murder and uh
now but their public reaction even to
when OPEC plus cut the production
really felt like they felt double
crossed yeah it wasn't so so much of
this really happened it really you could
just watch television and see that the
this was unfolding but the one month
aspect of it is really what's most
damage I say good I I am uh man hearing
that Joe Biden is reeling from this
makes it fills me with um what's that uh
shot in Freud yeah because Joe Biden has
hampered U.S energy production Joe Biden
said that he wants to get get us off
fossil fuels he's he's bragged about it
he campaigned on it congratulations you
will now reap what you have sown you
wanted to shut down Keystone you wanted
to ban fracking you wanted to you want
to deny permits for energy exploration
in the United States I get it a lot of
people are concerned about carbon and
fossil fuels and Hot Stuff great now
those people who are angry can go look
at the pump and ask themselves why it
costs so much money but hey as long as
they know they're making it more
expensive for themselves I got no
problem with them advocating for
something they believe in the problem is
these people are screaming there's that
viral video where This Woman's like it
was 95 to fill up my tank the religious
right did this no you did it to yourself
you voted for Joe Biden who bragged
about doing it and now because of this
because he campaigned on what you wanted
he goes and he bends the need of Saudi
Arabia and he says come on man please
please we need gas we don't produce it
anymore because of me and then they
laugh and they say nah it's okay we're
gonna work with Russia on this one and
then he pouts and he's a temper tantrum
and says and we're going to cut off aid
from your country and then the media
dances around the fact that this is
overt corruption on behalf of the
president who has done two things he has
hampered energy production in the U.S
for political gain and then he begs
Saudi Arabia to to give to make
concessions to the United States just so
we can win win the midterms and when
they don't do it he and other Democrats
threaten them talk about corrupt garbage
there's also a lot of other things
happening behind the scenes
geopolitically a lot of people are
saying Saudi Arabia's Russia but I think
it's even beyond that because Saudi
Arabia makes most of their money selling
oil what has this Administration
promised to do get off oil this directly
is going to piss off the Saudi Arabians
who are saying our whole economy is at
stake here especially if the whole
Western world gets off oil why are you
pushing these policies this is going to
of course hurt us financially so now
they're at a situation saying you know
what these people are not going to be
dependent on us so let's just take what
we could get right now let's make sure
we get a good profit off of the the
stupid policies put on by Joe Biden that
of course hindered domestic energy
exploration and production this is a
deliberate action by the Biden
Administration that just blew back in
its face
um and and correctly so people should be
pissed people should be angry that the
government tried to bamboozle them for a
month try to to lie to them for a month
just for a better rating just for a
better outcome when it came to the
midterm elections that's just disgusting
I want to show you this this is CNBC
reporting Biden Administration as Saudi
Arabia to postpone OPEC decision by a
month and this is CNBC saying notably
the White House's request would have
delayed the decision until after the U.S
midterm elections and just that there
was no long-term protection of gas
prices for the American people it was
literally just just wait one month
what would that accomplish let's say the
election has nothing to do with it what
does a one-month delay do for anyone
does it end the war no does it stop
Russia from financing their work no it
all would just carry on all it does the
one thing is it protects Democrats by
keeping gas prices just slightly
slightly down up until the midterm
elections and then afterwards off a
cliff yeah Rasmussen also says that
there's a direct statistical correlation
between approval ratings and gas prices
so of course they try to bamboozle they
try to lie they try to manipulate the
situation just so they could get more
power that they're going to of course
use to screw you over even more which is
crazy let me just I want to fill in the
picture of the quid pro quo here's CNBC
again Biden threatens consequences for
Saudi Arabia after OPEC cut but his
options are limited they are outright
telling you right now the president is
threatening this country because they
wouldn't help him his party win an
election now we have the guardian
Democrats issue fresh ultimatum to Saudi
Arabia over oil production
and these people men this is dirty what
do you do what do we do well what it
means to read I mean that's one way we
can we can do things but also you know
become more knowledgeable on what's
going on I read the response from the
Saudi Arabian Kingdom the last uh it's a
great it's a short read it's like eight
ten paragraphs the last paragraph says
the kingdom affirms that it uh it it
view it's a typo did it view it's or
maybe it's not it view its relationship
with the United States of America it's a
strategic one that serves the interests
of both countries it's very plainly
saying yo we're only doing this because
it benefits us both don't screw us over
there are they a nuclear power at this
point I believe that have we given them
all the nuclear secrets they have
nuclear bomb there's there's rumors that
they did get a nuclear bomb I think the
U.S intelligence at this point I think
they're very happy to cut ties with the
liberal economic order if they get
screwed yep that's why they've already
been like look OPEC plus includes Russia
right so so they're outright just like
we're good screw you you and when
remember when uh Anthony blinken was
talking to the Chinese a Chinese
official and China said to his face you
are not negotiating from a position of
power
man the U.S has come a long way when
Donald Trump was President he really was
reigniting something about America
whether you like it or not there was
fear that people looked at America as
like
Trump was a was a wild card he was a
Madman for the you know in the good way
and the bad way now under Joe Biden it's
a joke Saudi Arabia is laughing at him
he's trying to play dirty politics so he
can win political power I think
ultimately it's going to blow up in
their face it's the economy stupid
Republicans I think they're going to see
Victory we've now got more polls a new
poll coming out saying that in the
toss-up States Republicans are up Five
Points so when you look at the generic
ballot it shows Democrats are leading
but that's polling people in aoc's
District we don't really care about that
they have so many districts that are so
blue and so lopsided that's why they're
all talking about why everything should
be decided by national popular vote now
but that's not the way the
Constitutional structure of this country
works for very good reason and you know
they're definitely they're desperate
they're reeling inflation in general is
has remained a problem gas prices are
going to go up again all of the things
that they were hoping would improve by
November aren't really looking that
inspiring you know it's funny there's a
bunch of memes going around where um it
was a Ted Cruz tweeted something did you
guys see this tweet from Ted Cruz where
he's like here's a list of problems that
have occurred under Biden's
Administration and it's like 12 things
and then I'm seeing all of these tweets
getting screenshot and shared where
they're like Republicans voted there
were bills to solve all of those
problems and Republicans voted no on all
of them and I'm like imagine being
stupid enough to think that was a
rebuttal the Republicans are not in the
majority and their votes are meaningless
in this capacity what you are actually
saying is that all of these problems
occurred with a democrat-controlled
Congress and executive branch meaning
every attempt to solve these problems
either didn't work or actually made the
problem problem happen in the first
place inflation reduction act you have
core inflation running at a 40-year high
inflation and reduction Act passed its
law President Biden signed it into law
so you can't really say that Republicans
voting against right this bill caused
inflation exactly but there are people
who who fall for this stuff I've been
thinking about the cost benefit analysis
of producing carbon in uh the United
States because it's dirty it's
admittedly dirty in fact I found out
just a few days ago I was watching an
interview with John fetterman the guy
was running for uh Congress and Senate
Senate in Pennsylvania and uh which is a
part of Chicago right and uh he lives
across or lived at that period across
the street from the last steel mill in
his town I mean he's just churning Out
Steel and he had a stroke so like was
that related to living across the street
from the steel mill I mean I can't say
it's unrelated I think I know that yeah
I think it might be related so I I think
any any industrial setting is going to
have a negative oh horribly dirty dirty
but at this point it's recapture the
carbon capture the carbon as it's coming
out of the smokestack don't just stop
producing it that's my opinion I I agree
and um I've actually had a lot of
conversations because of what you've
said Ian about graphene carbon capture
from the atmosphere for the production
of graphene and whether it's for the
production of graphene or not it's a
really interesting point because we talk
about well we talk about the turn of the
century in New York where they were they
were scared that horse manure would be
everywhere then we invented cars and all
of a sudden there was Zero horse manure
look at that the problem solved it's a
technology solved the problem now we
have carbon in the atmosphere a
technology will come about and it will
solve this problem it will shift a new
there will be a new problem we'll
eventually solve I've I have tremendous
confidence in human Ingenuity and
technological advancement yeah Larry
Fink the CEO of BlackRock was just
talking about carbon but he what he was
talking about carbon sequestration and
how it's happening and it's getting the
private sectors taking on it's going to
be bigger and bigger deal and more
important but he's still considered
referred to it as like carbon reduction
and it's not it's carbon transmutation
you're taking it from one form and
turning it into another form but you're
not reducing the amount of it you're
just re repopulating you're replacing it
Luke who is the carbon they are trying
to reduce you you now but the funny
thing is when they talk about population
reduction and they do they talk about
you know outside of any kind of
conspiracies you actually have Bill
Gates saying we need to slow population
growth they're quite literally saying
the humans
that they they want to reduce that you
are the carbon yeah I mean once you you
reduce energy you reduce human potential
and human growth so I I think that's why
there's a deliberate agenda to say hey
no you know we got to get off fossil
fuels hey we have to get off this
particular energy source we have to get
off something that of course has been
running and helping humans progress in
society and that is just absolutely
detrimental that's going to lead to
Absolute havoc and I think it's very
fair to say that we are fast approaching
a situation that is going to tank the
economy deliberately in order to bring
on the central controller so they could
come in and come in with their solutions
to the problems that they caused I want
to take you back in time my friends I
want to give you a warm memory something
that you can take and press to your
bosom and feel good at night and it is a
story from Snopes Snopes I know I can
already hear the gasps from the crowd
did U.S gas prices drop below two
dollars under Trump they want you to
forget gas was under two dollars when
Trump was in office one Twitter user
posted claim national gas price averages
for regular fuel dropped below two
dollars per gallon during U.S president
Trump's term in office Snopes has
determined this to be
true
in early October 2022 received increase
from readers who asked if it is true the
national average gas price fell under
two dollars per gallon that's right a
dollar eighty four per gallon in April
2020. they do want you to forget it
because right now as you are being
squeezed out with a near four dollar
average across the country and it going
up Joe Biden is desperately begging
Saudi Arabia to postpone it just long
enough for them to win the midterms so
while that is going on and Joe Biden is
being is facing well we'll see if
there's any real consequences but as
long as we're talking about it and
calling him out while he's facing that
news story I want to make sure everybody
remembers guess dropped below two
dollars under Trump yeah wait wait I'm
sorry I'm sorry there's here's the uh
I want to give a shout out because they
did change the article
when I tweeted this story out the claim
said national gas prices for regular
fuel dropped below two dollars per
gallon during U.S president Donald
Trump's first term in office
and I tweeted that screenshot 6X and
Hammer responded pointing to first term
and then said they know
they're implying Trump's going to win
he's going to come back in 2024. well
this definitely gives them an
opportunity to do so and as you guys
know I'm not a big fan of Donald Trump
but under his administration imported
oil dropped by 25 he did allow
exploration he did allow production
which brought more oil on the World
Market and with more oil the demand of
it went down and the price of it went
down as well so when you look at those
kind of policies they did make a huge
impact because when you have cheap
energy you have an ability for human
beings to to progress and on that marker
Donald Trump has something to stand on
and brag about since of course this
Administration is doing the opposite of
that and wreaking havoc on our financial
system deliberately it's funny it's like
we were a net exporter of fuel weren't
we you know in 2020 and uh gas price was
dirt cheap and now we're desperately
importing and gas is very expensive
how's that and it's it's just a series
of self-inflicted problems I mean the
border is a self-inflicted problem the
energy costs or a self-inflicted problem
problem
all of the money we're spending in
Ukraine is largely I mean obviously it's
to some degree a Putin inflicted problem
but it's largely a self-inflicted
problem I want to pause there and and
put a note on that Putin did start this
war but the U.S but the United States
choosing to be involved is a
self-inflicted problem that's right yes
absolutely and and to be involved
without any scrutiny without any end
goal without any uh how do I'm sorry how
does this happen there's no declaration
of war how is it that we get roped into
sending billions of dollars with 100
billion what's the number so far we
didn't vote on this Congress didn't did
did Congress declare war and say that
we're we're able to to do this the 40
billion they voted on and but somebody
yeah the drawdown packages and all of
those things those don't come from
Congress at all this is This Is War this
is providing intelligence and resources
to fight Russia
and what they don't need to declare war
in this capacity we're going to be
dragged into it now I mean if if they're
allowed to get away with this then there
never will be I mean there hasn't been
they've not declared war since what
World War II declaration of war has kind
of become one of those dead letters it's
sort of a nicety they're reducing the
Constitution to really the Roberts Rules
of Order like the the process related
things of like how many people get to
serve in Congress what their ages of
Eligibility are we take those things
very seriously enumerated power is not
very much
I'm looking at the average crude oil
price and it is true in April 2020 it
was 21 bucks uh but in like January of
2020 it was 61. so it dropped massively
and then the pandemic struck and then it
would start just to scale back up up to
100 and so from like 21 in April 2020 to
116. six times five times the amount in
June and it's got it's got to be
correlating with inflation which is also
self-inflicted I think if you look at
the average of his presidency it was
like two thousand Thirty cents or
something so even if we were to take out
that that you know that low point
it was still better under Trump and it's
simple when Trump is is is green
lighting energy exploration and
production
speculation on these things are that
there's going Supply will meet demand
and so the price stabilizes when Joe
Biden comes in and starts axing permits
and shutting down pipelines speculation
is that we will not have a supply to
meet demand and the price skyrockets
just from speculation alone not to
mention we do have now A reduced Supply
and then we we go you know Biden goes to
Saudi Arabia and says we desperately
need production to go up and they say no
so what does Biden do he drains the
Strategic petroleum Reserve he's like
imagine I want you to imagine this way
your roommate quits his job
no longer making any money and you're
like bro you need a job no no no don't
worry I'm gonna ask my mom my mom will
give me money my mom's gonna my mom's
good she's gonna give me money and then
every time
his mom says no he goes into your rainy
day fund and pulls cash and says no no
don't worry don't worry it's just we
gotta pay the rent you know but but my
mom will come through and now the rainy
day jar is almost empty I I'm thinking
about like well the Strategic oil
Reserve is that the low it's it's one of
its lowest points in in decades so now
you have to think about it you know this
was predominantly I I believe correct me
if I'm wrong was created because of
World War II just so the United States
has enough oil and energy to actually
fight a war so with these levels being
low we're not really at preparedness
levels from from a lot of an analyst's
perspectives to be able to fight a war
now if there is a war now we're kind of
stuck in a very bad situation that's
what exactly I was thinking is it seems
like whoever's in charge in command
which is obviously the
commander-in-chief the President Joe
Biden uh doesn't has this like illusion
that we're invulnerable or something
like the way they surrendered in
Afghanistan and like let all those
people die and let all that
infrastructure however many billions of
dollars worth of uh equipment left over
for the Taliban without you think
there's no consequences because we're
America No One's Gonna attack us we're
fine like you can't just cut off the oil
that fuels the Jets and the bombers and
the tanks and the planes and the
factories that make the steel and and
the the Plastics that we use for all of
our phones and our roads and our like
and and expect that no one's going to
attack Us in the meantime while we don't
have a supply that's when countries get
attacked is when they're when they're at
their weakest you need a defensive
mechanism in place well at the same time
he was doing all of this too he was
attacking domestic oil producers to
attacking domestic energy producers and
saying that they're the reason that
prices are up and it's price gouging and
he's really done this with with every
vaguely inflation related topic I mean
all politicians to some extent do this
but Biden's really Brazen everything
going wrong in the economy is some
external factor that is outside of his
control he has nothing to do with it
everything that goes right in the
economy is a direct result of his policy
it's price hike if you remember he's
been saying it's just transitory it's
it's great that it's here it's actually
good that it's here I actually started
my video off today with a compilation of
Biden within the last two years saying
hey you know inflation it's not here
it's transitory it's crazy and you just
see the progression progression of it
and now we are here with new inflation
numbers that should terrify people as of
course these are manipulated numbers and
the real life numbers are a lot more
daunting that of course aren't really
published aren't really talked about but
should be if you live long enough
everything is transitory that's right
yes life is transitory yeah so this
whole War don't worry it's transitory
yeah for 20 some odd years we got to
experience Afghanistan amazing well I
want to add it to uh to Joe Biden he is
uh he is what's the right way to phrase
this he has accomplished what his
detractors thought he would accomplish
but boy did he do it tenfold and did it
faster than people expected I mean I
knew war was coming I was saying like
look you vote for buying we're gonna get
War I didn't know it was going to be
world war three wow you know well beyond
my expectations Biden you did it it's
like uh it's like bowling a perfect game
of gutterballs it's like well you you
have consistency there but we didn't
think you'd do that bad
there you go yeah I remember when Biden
first got in I'm like the probability
and chances of us going towards high now
100 in Ukraine and it's been absolutely
true now you know this leads us to kind
of question is it because he's a bad
leader is it because he's a failed
leader is it because he's an incompetent
leader or is this a part of a bigger
ruse a bigger plan in order to bring
something else in that will of course
profit and benefit off of these problems
that are being deliberately caused right
now it could be both because I do think
he is incompetent well based on the
Afghanistan surrender that is the most
incompetent use of the American Military
I've ever heard of to lose that war that
we are winning to give up to the Taliban
and let them take over like that I I
gotta disagree with you I think that was
an act of pure competence it was
intentional you do not accidentally
abandon an Air Force Base in the middle
of the night that can't be an accident
no it's one thing it was intentional
which is like plus the United States has
the United States has military protocol
to blow up and to literally send in
fighter jets to to destroy U.S equipment
before they go into enemies hands they
failed to do that with Isis in Northern
Iraq before Isis got all the Humvee
vehicles and they failed to do that here
in Afghanistan as well
so when I when I say it was competence
it wasn't that they made a bad call it
was the right call for exactly what they
wanted to happen they know what they're
doing you don't accidentally say okay
everybody at 3am quickly flee and the
Riders and looters come and take
everything that just doesn't happen yeah
I would think it wouldn't nobody in
their right mind would do something like
that and not only that they could have
done the evacuations through the
Fortified Air Force Base it could have
taken eight months they could have told
the Taliban to suck it we're leaving
when we're leaving it doesn't matter
what day we told you it's War deal with
it air support got pulled all of a
sudden the the air superiority was gone
Taliban started rushing in Afghans
security forces were getting we're
getting massacred yeah that was I I view
that all as intentional well in the one
foreign policy question that Biden has
been right about in his entire career
was that the U.S Western supported
Afghan government was fake that it was
corrupt it was fake it wasn't real
and yet he premised at least publicly
his entire withdrawal strategy on that
government being able to hold long
enough for everybody to get out when his
own predictions had said that there was
just without U.S support that government
couldn't exist yeah especially the air
support I mean they were heavily reliant
on the logistics that the United States
was providing and then without the
logistics they were empty it was like a
a bunch of people that didn't know who
was where it was a Warren Zevon
government send Lawyers Guns and Money
And if you don't send those things there
is no government let's jump to the story
from The Daily Beast
Ukraine joining NATO guaranteed to start
World War III Russian official says the
war in Ukraine is guaranteed to escalate
into World War III if Kiev is allowed to
join NATO according to a Russian
Security Council official Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski made a
surprise announcement that he had made a
first a fast track bid for membership
blah blah we know a lot of this all of
NATO's 30 members would have to approve
Ukraine's bid making full membership of
the defense group a long way off Kiev is
well aware that such a step would mean a
guaranteed escalation to World War III
so um and then here's a quote here's a
quote the suicidal nature of such a step
is understood by NATO members themselves
maybe one NATO country is just going to
say no we do not want to vote Yes on
being dragged into a nuclear war
but the one thing I can say
is that if you are between the ages of
17 and 24
because I don't think it'll happen right
now but you know that that draft age and
you support this war well I'm I'm that
I'm actually looking forward to you
being drafted
you go fight the war that you supported
all of these gen's ears with the little
Ukrainian flags and their Twitter bios
I'm actually excited to see you guys go
through basic training and then go be
the Canon fodder for the wealthy Elites
who want to win this region of Eastern
Europe how about that I would go even
further if you're a politician calling
for work go fight it you're more than
welcome Joe you're more than welcome to
join the armed you know forces what's
stopping you if you really want this go
go and get it and I think that's how we
should be treating these situations if
we had an evolved Humanity that said you
know what we're not fighting these
stupid Wars we're not going to die for
politicians we're not we're not going to
die for these people that are selling
arms and making a profit off of this
nonsense
um we're not there we're at a phase
where of course we have a lot of lunacy
we have a lot of insanity and a lot of
escalations to this conflict that are
absolutely nonsensical there's no
purpose to us there's no larger agenda
here what's the goal here why are we
doing this can you even explain that
they can't there's no rational argument
for what's happening right now let me
ask you guys
is there uh is there a circumstance
where you agree with an offensive
invasion
is there a circumstance where you think
the U.S should declare war preemptively
and then invade a country before being
attacked
I mean that's that's a very open-ended
question there could be many differences
you probably can right
before being attacked I don't know so
the U.S sitting there mind its own
business there's another country that's
minding its own business but they may be
engaging in some activities is there a
circumstance where they don't attack you
but you think it is Justified to invade
that country well if you're talking
about a situation where you know they
are going to attack you that that can be
justified but what we've done in Iraq
and what we've seen other and what for
some degree Russia has done in Ukraine
is theoretically something is going to
happen someday that will allow them to
threaten us or attack us and we need to
attack them first before that happens
and that way lies Madness well that's
what uh zielinski said he called for
preemptive strikes on Russia he is also
causing calling for preemptive strikes
yep well then he walked it back no oh I
meant um reactive sanctions yeah
sanctions which there's already a bunch
of sanctions right wouldn't do anything
to deter in fact it would just
exacerbate the problem
I wonder I wonder if there if there ever
really is I'm sure a lot of the more
libertarian types are probably like no
there is no matter what some other
country is doing so long as they're not
attacking you you should not invade them
I think there are instances where a
military buildup could be uh you know a
cause for war like if like Germany
building up the tanks that it was
building up before World War II if if
France had been like this is too risky
to have that on our border because what
happened was they blitzcrigged and they
took Paris like within two weeks it was
theirs and uh that's what if you let
someone go full hog that's why they
built the liberal economic order was to
prevent other countries from going full
hog
but imagine you have a neighbor and
every day you say you see your neighbor
buying more and more guns
and uh he's got a massive Arsenal you
can see it through the window does that
justify you going over there having him
arrested his property confiscated or
saying that this guy is clearly going to
be attacking someone I better stop him I
don't see it now but there is there is
an analogy it's it's if you saw through
your neighbor's window him mercilessly
beating a child you would kick the door
in and you would get physical with this
man
or you'd call the police but if it was
mercilessly being a child for the safety
of that child to stop this act you would
invade that house right that's also why
that's usually the argument used for
invasions exactly it's never just that
okay they may threaten us although those
arguments are usually used too it's
about whatever humanitarian bad things
are going on in that country and let's
face it in most of the world a lot of
bad things are going on a lot of
governments are bad governments doing
bad things I'd say all of them yeah
preach sorry go ahead it's not very much
of a limiting principle for war if
you're going to justify it on that basis
but but then there's the next level of
the United States and other governments
staging these kind of events that are
not true that have no basis in reality
just like we saw in the first Gulf War
with the baby incubator story with
literally a PR team working for the
government engineering a story that the
Iraqi government was taking babies from
incubators and just murdering them like
like they they were just sociopaths that
story completely made up by a PR agency
that led to the first Gulf War there was
public hearings there was videos all of
them fake manipulated because again they
needed a justification so they made one
up they had like a young girl speak to
the UN about it yes and she was uh the
daughter of an ambassador
um that again was coached and staged to
lie on National Television that she
personally saw the babies taken out of
the incubators which was such a horrible
it's insane just just visualization that
it shocked people emotionally to say
yeah we got to stop this yeah remember
when they were I think uh the Russians
fired missiles into Ukraine like five or
six days ago or something like that I
think there were missiles or bombs or
whatever and then oh the the variety of
airstrikes yeah yeah and then all of a
sudden this video of uh the United
States invasion of Iraq shows up from
2003 what they call shock and awe and
the idea was we're gonna hit him as hard
as we can as fast as we can so that they
don't even have a defense prepared they
can't they just surrender and it was
televised and I remember sitting in the
bar in Chicago watching it and like
getting excited because I thought they
had weapons of mass destruction that's
what I was told and I was like good
we're gonna stop a tyrant from nuking
the world and I was excited like the way
that you can and and that propaganda man
the way that you can view bombing a city
as a good thing or bombing it as a
reason for war like the crazy emotions
that are involved with that I think for
me I was probably lucky that I was you
know Through Skateboarding introduced a
lot of punk rock elements anti-war
elements so as soon as this all started
the only thing I knew was here's why
it's bad so there was never like I'm not
going to pretend that when I was like
you know 14 15 16 I was this political
genius no I was just some dumb kid
listening to punk rock being like hey
war is bad and then I got older and I
started seeing the stories I started
learning the politics because that that
music got me interested in more
interested in politics and then I was
just outright like yo this is nuts what
they're doing and then Obama comes along
and he's like if you vote for me we're
gonna end the wars and I was like okay I
dig this and this is like my first
presidency and all my friends are like
he's gonna do it man Bush was Hitler and
we're going to get Obama he's changed
he's you know he's going to be the first
black president and I was like all right
you know I'll vote for this guy and then
he right when he gets in office whistle
strike on a Pakistani Village killing
women and children and I was just like I
was pissed I was super pissed I was like
my friends didn't care anymore they're
like oh I don't know what's going on
they stopped paying attention
immediately because it was all a big
propaganda machine I don't think that
there was an actual anti-war movement
for the most part during the bush era I
think it was a Democrat propaganda
movement seeking to exploit the anti-war
effort because they wanted to get a
democrat in office if you look at a lot
of anti-war marches there's a lot of
recruitment for other left-wing causes
that have very little to do with Wars
um yeah and it is it's sort of a
movement building exercise to a certain
extent
yeah
man that was that was uh disheartening
to say the least yeah I thought there
was they made me believe that a savior
was gonna save me like Obama was the
savior is what I felt like and I could
actually take a back seat but that's not
you know you're the you're the driver in
this room well that's almost every
president especially in recent history
George W bush ran on a foreign policy of
non-interventionalism global foreign
policy a humble foreign policy that
doesn't get involved in other countries
Affairs that's what he promised and then
the dude just bombed a whole bunch of
countries saying screw I'm gonna do what
I want give my buddy Dick Cheney
Halliburton whatever he wants and they
lied they lied through their teeth most
wars are based on false pretenses we
could go all the way back from 1898 with
the USS Maine we could go to the
reichtag fire we could go to the Gulf of
Tonkin we could talk about these events
on and on and on and the truth is
there's probably these events happening
right now that the American public
doesn't even know about oh dude all the
videos coming out out of Ukraine and
probably and just one less thing
probably another event that they're
preparing for right now that's going to
lead to a bigger War so I I think that's
a big possibility that I've been
speaking about that we should be looking
out for every single video on Reddit
or Twitter it's always like yeah go
Ukraine and then it's like some
Ukrainian Soldier like flicking a
cigarette an explosion there's another
video where it's like a Russian and
Ukrainian drone got into a sky Fight
ukrainians Win and I'm just like dude
it is like it's propaganda and that's
why I'm annoyed by it they intentionally
want to filter out anything that could
shift morale in this I get it but for me
it is the most annoying thing in the
world when I'm sitting here going like I
know you are lying okay this maybe works
on other people fine leave me out of it
I can look up and see what's actually
going on I can make uh assumptions and
inferences based on the information
received but I'll tell you this 100 of
videos being showing Ukraine winning and
I'm just like spare me okay I'm tired of
it they used video game footage to
promote the ghost of Kiev yup I mean how
how dumb do you think we are the media
ran with it these people these people
ran with it and it was never corrected
there was never any kind of real
legitimate checks on that specific story
and again I understand propaganda
efforts during war are very uh you know
clearly used against the general public
because they know information is key
when it comes to winning the larger
conflict here but but at least try to
put on a genuine an effort and not to
treat people like other idiots here well
the video gamification of War has been
30 years or more in the in the running
and and a lot of people in comfortable
countries where they're unlikely to have
to serve in any of these wars or fight
in any of these wars do kind of look at
it like they're watching a movie or
playing a video game and you just get to
see cool explosions
that's right this uh this Invasion that
Russia just propagated they're they
basically annexed Crimea which was old
Soviet I think and then uh now they're
trying to take the land bridge to Crimea
that's like what the war is about it's
not about killing people it's not about
genocide but potential potentially
lithium oxide I think in Crimea or
I've seen some reports about that well
there's a lot of untapped natural gas
resources in those specific regions that
the Russians are having uh under control
right now that are in contention with
the Ukrainian army fighting them I I
think it's the land bridge though
because look they blow up the Crimea
Bridge how is Russia supposed to get
access to Crimea without that bridge
they need another you know those two
highways right yeah they need the land
bridge so I think Armistice is like the
only way out is it some sort of peace
agreement negotiation but what would it
be what would be an effective
negotiation do you see to piece of land
how about we just have them sit at the
table there's people saying you're crazy
you must be you must be a Putin
supporter you must be a peace Nick if
you if you let's just have them sit at
the table and talk to each other at
least let's get to that step we're not
even there zielinski passed the law
saying I'm not negotiating even restated
it I'm not going to be negotiating why
at least talk to each other that's the
first step because let's do that in the
bill yeah he must have some like nasty
video of Joe Biden doing something you
know I think it's funny because they
kept people kept claiming that Putin had
compromat on Trump and I'm like yeah but
what was Trump doing for Russia like he
bombed Syria like you know a half-assed
bombing now you're looking at 100
billion dollars or whatever going to
Ukraine now that sounds like somebody's
got dirt on you yeah because the US why
are we involved in this well Trump sent
lethal weapons to Ukraine as well which
was a big escalation in this entire
conflict there was also a bigger
conflict that could have unfolded with
Iran that luckily didn't unfold but but
but again at the end of the day here the
fact that these people aren't even
willing to negotiate is something that
should be very troubling because if
you're not negotiating if you're not
just coming to the table just to talk
let these people figure it out I don't
have the answers Elon Musk came up with
a proposition it wasn't a perfect
proposition for a peace deal but at
least the conversation was started and I
think the more people call for peace the
more likely we could actually have it
because right now all you're seeing is
deranged lunatic saying war war war with
absolutely no goal in sight and that to
me is reckless that to me is stupid
what's the what's the Strategic
objective here why hasn't anyone told us
this have you guys bought your burnt
hair perfume to help Elon buy Twitter no
not yet I bought that joke so many times
and I think I should get a cut of this
money about him buying I mean burnt
burned hair I didn't know that he would
have that be the same but I think Elon
Musk your name is musk you have to have
a clone yeah elon's mask please yeah I
need it in my nose it's not the way it
sounds Elon I need it
um yeah I agree with you Luke we need
some sort of diplomacy it could be a
simple video chat with Joe Biden and
Vladimir Putin that's public and they
could be so easy well the United States
of NATO has to be a part of these
negotiations since they're a part of
this conflict and Vladimir Putin just
made a statement a couple days ago
saying that he's willing to actually uh
be open to negotiations during the
upcoming G20 meeting will the West
respond with other negotiations will
they be open to sitting down and talking
to them because this was beyond just
zelinski and and Putin zielinski should
be there obviously zielinski and the
Ukrainian government should be sitting
down with the Russian government and at
least talking to each other in some kind
of capacity in some kind of way
um and and those talks should at least
be between those two countries what do
they want let's let's figure out a way
where they're both happy and it doesn't
have to mean people are getting screwed
over people getting lied about doesn't
mean you're a Putin agent that you just
want conversations to happen I think
there's a desire though to see a
degradation of the Russian military
which they think is most likely to
happen if this conflict continues
but the odd thing is that he called up
300 000 troops so like if you want to
see us conscripts yeah so if you want to
see a weaker military it's not by
forcing them to draft 300 000 people
that's well it also looks like it might
not be the greatest Fighters though to
have from the latest bombings that have
been happening in Ukraine it does look
like the Russians are trying to take out
uh the major air defense systems inside
of Ukraine it looks like they're
preparing for a major bombing campaign
of Ukraine there's also a ton of Russian
soldiers being shipped into Belarus and
there's a lot of rumors that Belarus
will also be participating in launch
another front of this war from the north
of Ukraine so there's a lot of things
happening behind the scenes that are
very much escalating the situation that
are very much unfortunate for all the
innocent people caught in the middle of
this because there's going to be a huge
loss of life I think we should be doing
everything in our power to try to
prevent that and sadly we have the
opposite of that when it comes to the
corporate media when it comes to the
leadership when it comes to the Victoria
Newland and all these other sociopathic
neoconservatives that just want blood
and that's not what I want want I want
the people of Ukraine I want the people
of Russia to to come together and at
least talk to each other let's uh let's
throw it to our good friend Alexandra
ocasio-cortez my friends I was saddened
and shocked at this deeply offensive
video of these belligerent
misogynists who are yelling at poor AOC
simply because she's funding War and the
azov Battalion and defending the
establishment what did she do wrong
other than all of those things all right
here's the reality AOC got heckled at a
virtually empty Town Hall in the Bronx
protester says she voted to start this
war in Ukraine and will push the US to
the brink of nuclear war Bravo to these
activists two guys calling her out
saying they believed in her and now
she's become a shill for the
establishment providing funding for war
and Nazis in Ukraine I love it and so I
tweeted this out in response to these
activists saying that I pulled up a
story from NBC NBC news saying Putin's
false Nazi claims about Ukraine and and
then I pulled up another story from NBC
News the Nazi problem in Ukraine Ukraine
is very real even if Putin is lying
about it so now they're outright just
saying it huh why is AOC the
anti-fascist the leftist
voting to give money to Nazis
why why is this why is she voting to
fund War
now Bravo for these guys speaking out
and calling her out but I think this is
the start we need this this is probably
our best our best Avenue in that the
older generation is going to ignore and
probably not care about uniparty voters
Democrats and Republicans who support
War but the younger generation is is
much more disillusioned and angry about
it AOC just knifed them all in the back
by by supporting all of this I don't
know why she is because she's a shield
she's always been a shill she's not
alone though I mean they're even when
you go back to previous Wars under
Democratic administrations when you go
back to Kosovo in the 90s when you go
back to Libya under Barack Obama there
was at least a subset there weren't they
weren't the mainstream Democrats but
they were a subset of progress
self-styled Progressive Democrats who
would vote against funding these wars
who would join lawsuits against
presidential Wars there really isn't
anything like that going on right now
every single Democrat in Congress voted
for the 40 billion dollar Aid package to
Ukraine and I don't know if these
activists heckling AOC mean that there
is still some Grassroots anti-war left
out there that is just not represented
by anybody in congress and if they start
speaking up maybe they will be or if
this is sort of the last gasp of that
sentiment it's it's die I mean Tulsi
gabbard was it right what about Bernie
is he's did he vote to send all the
money
Bernie did too huh yeah they're not a
single one didn't Barbara Lee rocana
people who are generally very good on a
lot of who've worked across the aisle on
things like Yemen uh have really been
nowhere to be seen on this one I think
Cortez is she's pretty responsive to the
crowd and this guy this Heckler I I
don't even know I'm not sure if Heckler
is the right because he wasn't insulting
her he was just screaming in panic that
if she doesn't stop this that we're
gonna die in a nuclear war and he's like
he's the terror in his voice is palpable
seems like he's not wrong she's she
responds to emotions so yeah definitely
I'm not encouraging people to go scream
at politicians but I mean they're there
to represent us and if they're not
representing us that we need to make our
voices heard Trump Russia is a big part
of this too the the fact that the whole
Trump Russia narrative became so big on
the left that Vladimir Putin where where
is is viewed by some Grassroots
Democrats is the man who installed
the orange man in in power in the United
States so that created a lot of
anti-russia sentiment among people who
maybe even during the Cold War when it
might have been more Justified didn't
have these types of sentiments so I
think there was more openness to
hawkishness against Russia because of
domestic political disputes and domestic
political tribalism that might have
existed otherwise especially among some
people on the center to hard left yeah a
lot of the anti-war representatives got
kicked out or pushed out or forced out
of their of their parties whether it's
kucinich or McKinney these were
individuals that of course were speaking
out against war and their districts were
moved around shoved around in a way
where of course they didn't have a
political career afterwards so you know
there is a deliberate effort to have a
pro-war message to have a message that
supports the military-industrial complex
a major Lobby in Washington DC so I I do
believe that a lot of people who had
significant voices are afraid of being
pushed out of politics for for doing so
I just had a thought is there we say the
military industrial complex are there
multiple I would imagine there are
multiple complexes there's one that the
liberal economic order is utilizing then
there must be another one that the
Chinese and the Russians yeah definitely
that's exactly what they are where's the
racket but then is there someone at the
top of those organizations that are
capitalizing on both of the uh complexes
is it unknown I don't know
I don't know
I don't think so I think you've got the
Western military industrial complex that
loves War because it guaranteed
contracts extremely expensive extremely
lucrative but I I I don't think that
there is this Grand cabal that controls
the military apparatus of China Russia
and the west and then pits them against
each other it's not like you know uh in
Sherlock Holmes when more we already got
the book and he's trying to orchestrate
World War One or whatever it's because
whoa is money
yeah I think you're right I don't think
there is somebody at the top I think the
bankers are profiting off of it well but
even then there's multiple they're
probably selling weapons across the
board they're playing both sides yeah I
mean look Obama was sending weapons to
the cartels now there's another story
emerging about something similar the gun
manufacturers being accused of sending
weapons to cartels nobody these
manufacturers don't care they just like
give me the money and the weapons are
yours
that's it yeah and I don't think you
can't sue the manufacturer if someone
does something horrible with their
weapon at least I don't think you can
well they're trying now especially yeah
but we're talking about war even yeah
it's like if we're at war with China
ain't nobody from China going to sue the
United States what are you doing we're
at War like actively killing each other
so I I'd like to say that um you know
we're moving away from all this stuff
but I think for a variety of reasons
there are many people very invested in a
nuclear apocalypse occurring
creepy people evil people calloused
people Tim they bought their nuclear
bunkers they want to use them okay they
want to make sure that their money was
well invested and they would they want
to make sure they are safe houses in New
Zealand and Chile are going to be used
well I mean look think about it if you
have uh if it's a publicly traded
nuclear bunker company and you have
equity in that when the nuclear war
happens that Stock's going straight
through the roof baby that's money right
that's rare now you won't be able to
trade anywhere because there won't be a
stock market Wall Street apps
electricity or food for that matter but
uh everybody will want what you got if
he bought a nuclear bunker don't you
want to use it yeah I think the answer
is no hold on the most expensive nuclear
bunker you buy is the one you buy and
never use yeah it's that old saying you
know but it's Insurance think of your
bunker as insurance not as a goal not as
a home retirement putting it on wedding
Registries and baby gifts for sure rent
it out you made a good point about the
video gamization of War man I think the
young there's an older generation that
has their nuclear bunkers these and
they're like I'm ready to go let's let's
find the next iteration of humanity
after this is all done but then there's
these young people that have been
brainwashed to think it's a freaking
video game and it's that's why they do
the video games yeah in America's Army
that was a specific video game that the
United States government used to train
kids to want to become troops yeah like
specifically I'm watching videos from
the Russian side the Ukrainian side from
a lot of the the battles that are taking
place the majority of of killing and
meaning is happening because of drones
the Russians are using Iranian suicide
drones that are just flying directly
into Ukrainian troops the ukrainians are
you using these quadcopters and they're
just putting grenades inside of them and
then having a button that releases them
and they're literally throwing them into
the Russian trenches and there's a whole
bunch of DJI drones there's a video that
I saw of a Ukrainian drone taking out a
Russian DJI drone yeah and when you look
at a lot of the footage it's straight
out of Call of Duty it's straight out of
all the video games where of course you
get a drone and you get the pilot a
missile you get to send grenades off and
and it's exactly like all the video
games that I played as a kid and and you
can see the footage online because I'm
keeping track of this I want to see
what's really going on I want to see
who's winning I want to see who's losing
I really want to get a real perspective
of what's happening there and you have
to see these videos and there's drones
predominantly drones having huge success
in these conflicts I had a friend that
worked in the military and he worked
with some people that were operating
drones told me this story where he the
guy was like you got to see this footage
man the Drone operator so he showed him
and it was the the missile or the bomb
was dropping on this guy who they
thought was working on bombs and it
comes up and you go it goes right up to
the guy you see it going right and the
guy looks up and you see his eyes and
then you realize he's taking a crap and
then the bomb hit and then it it goes
off that's it and but he's like I saw
his eyes like I
that's one way to help you poop
yep they probably just went right into
the toilet as soon as he saw that and
then of course exited his body in every
possible Direction when it did yeah they
thought he was like going to get weapons
and he was just out there like
taking a big old dog but it's so easy
when it's a video game to disassociate
yeah we talked about that a while ago
about Vietnam how and they send out
these conscripts they would fire above
the the Vietcong or whatever because
they really didn't want to shoot him and
so they started implementing new uh
that's when I think they made the
targets and the shapes of people and
stuff like that and then now video games
have become a component of this it's
interesting because there's a
distinction
video games don't make people more
violent we've seen all the studies on
this someone who plays a video game
doesn't all of a sudden be like now I
want to be violent but what video games
do is they they condition you so when it
comes to being violent it is easier for
you to pull the trigger so people who
already have those Tendencies when it
comes to war and conflict you're used to
playing these games you you have a
simulated experience it's it's going to
have an effect on you dude have you seen
escape from tarkov the game it's a first
person shooters hyper realistic and you
fight Russians man you hear the rush
they're screaming in Russian it's crazy
that's like most Call of Duties this is
new yeah I was going to say in One Call
of Duty there's a scene where you play a
child as your city in in Syria is
literally getting gassed and you're
playing as the child running away from
the Russian gas as they said chemical
weapons Call of Duty and yeah one of the
Call of Duty modern warfare games so
you're literally a child running away
from a Russian soldier that that wants
to stab you as there's a chemical uh you
know weapons attack I love how like
America's adversaries are always comic
book villains you know it's like when
you watch the media they you know
Vladimir Putin the evil dictator
murdered children today and it's like
come on man they're adults who
understand why War happens and they want
you to believe that every world leader
is wearing a cloak and a top hat with a
mustache going I'm going to tie a woman
to the railroad tracks no he's probably
saying hey you're pushing your military
Alliance up upon my border and it's and
it's it's it's jeopardizing my country's
interests and I'm not gonna let that
happen and he's probably like yo let me
ship steel down to Crimea so I can sail
it over to the United States and sell it
to you like it's I it's so weird it's so
like almost disbelievable that we're
creating an enemy out of the Russian
Federation when it could be our greatest
trade Ally and strongest partner
military partner on Earth it's on the
other side of the planet we could
together protect the planet well Ian
I've got good news for you from Newsweek
U.S states that wish to join Russia will
be considered says Duma member oh well
good news if you're an American state
and you want to vote to join Russia
they're listening they say a senior
member of the state Duma Russia's
Parliament said that any U.S states that
want to break away from the country and
instead join the Russian Federation will
be considered how hilarious would it be
if Russia tries pulling off something in
Alaska like Crimea like all the alaskans
had a vote and 80 want to be Russian and
it would vindicate Sarah Palin yeah
that's right well that was actually Tina
Fey
yeah same Tina Fey same person I guess
the comments come only a week after
Russia declared the four regions of
Ukraine it become Russian territory blah
blah blah I love this one it's actually
really funny because we're uh we're
constantly talking about Civil War and
peaceful divorce and I think they
actually bring this up they say that the
US was beginning to Decay and that its
Ally the European Union which has also
provided strong military assistance
Ukraine was bursting at its seams
tomachev said this was the result of
failed American foreign policy such
initiatives are a signal that the
citizens of the U.S are dissatisfied
with their leadership and are ready to
take Extreme Measures up to secession if
the current policy of America continues
I mean look there are a lot of people in
the U.S that actually think Russia is
the good guy in this I think that's
wrong but people believe it so what
happens if you get enough people in a in
a I don't know in the North Pacific
Northwest and they're just like
yeah yeah we don't want this I mean when
you look at what's going on in Portland
and and and Seattle with the wokeness
and everything you might actually start
getting sympathizers yeah la New York
too la
I don't think realistically I don't
think anyone's going to want to become
Russian in the United States I mean
maybe some people might but I don't
think that any like organization would
think that would be better because the
United States is pretty awesome well
that's it would be a military risk too
but people did that they'd be labeled
Traders seditionists and executed
immediately well it bombed and executed
it wouldn't make sense but the the
founding fathers
also you know we're traitors to the
crown
so there are people who who think that
the people who talk about wokeness and
the cabal
there are many of these people who think
Vladimir Putin is a traditionalist he's
Christian and he's fighting against
Satanism and Evil
there are people in the US who believe
that but the founding fathers they just
split off and form their own country
they didn't join like France or anything
if they right that probably wouldn't
might have I'm just saying that I don't
think they would have got what they
wanted there are going to be people I
mean hey look man in war you get
separatists you get partisans and
infighting breaks out I think Victor
Orban would have more success though
getting some people to join Hungary than
uh than anybody that's true Russia yeah
I mean Hungary has really attracted a
lot of people but I will also mention
that there are a lot of people
associated with the far right or
whatever you'd call it in the U.S who
have praised Ukraine for some time
there's many people who have moved to
Ukraine well before the conflict broke
out because they support more you know
traditional heavily traditional policies
so joining Russia I mean not me but man
is it uh rocking a hard place Russia I'm
not a fan of
um I'm a fan of the country the history
the people but the government is what I
mean to say the United States it's kind
of the same thing I would I would rather
a I would trust Biden and the US
government only slightly more than
anyone else and it's simply because they
live here and so at least we have some
shared interests and not wanting to get
blown up but man Joe Biden is crooked I
do not think he's doing anything for the
American people so the question is how
do you protect what this country is
supposed to be the Constitution and its
people when you have crackpots corrupts
cronies who are running the show
decentralization and personal
responsibility where you don't need them
and you're not dependent on them or
their money and uh you know I think
individuals could take small actions I
think it starts at a community level and
it builds up from there and I think you
just got to be the best example of an
individual who doesn't need the state
and is there for themselves and could be
fully independent so peaceful divorce
um you wouldn't even have to divorce
it's just a different style of living
living locally instead of fawning from
the feds just like the Amish and other
communities of individuals saying you
know hey we want to take care of
ourselves you guys do what you guys want
but as long as you're not harming anyone
there's there's there shouldn't be any
problems here the thing about that it's
not as a super I think it's not super
appealing to a lot of people because
it's not like a switch you flip and then
get a solution but it's like a long-term
uh solution it could become a solution
to you know overarching federalism I
mean in theory you don't even really
need a divorce for this to happen you
just have to honor the terms of the
marriage yeah but we're not really
honoring the terms of the marriage as
sort of the problem on that front you
know what it is like you know back in
the day the husband and the wife were
sleeping in different beds at least on
TV right and then all of a sudden they
started sharing a bed well first they
slid their beds together yeah then is
that what happened to the TV the pads
were pushed together yeah that was the
first was that the first one is that the
first married couple sleeping in the bed
with two beds well known real life they
used to do that I think but anyway
actually sleep in separate beds yeah but
then they'd slide them together and then
they'd but anyway I'm a proponent for
that you get a lot more restful sleep
when you're in a separate bed by
yourself
that's why they make mattresses that you
know like can adjust and go up and down
have different firmness and different
temperatures but you see my point is you
know the United States used to be we all
slept in separate beds and then at some
point we're all sleeping in the same bed
and it's not working out oh yeah you're
looking snow and your feet I'm waking up
man it's turn the heat up they steal the
blanket all the time you're out from
that fan in the ceiling you know look
I'm I'm over here in West Virginia
minding my own business and Maryland is
is grabbing the blanket and spinning
slowly throughout the night wrapping
themselves up like a burrito I'm waking
up freezing like dude fine I'll get my
own blanket and then they're like you're
calling for a divorce it's like maybe I
should just have my own blank you should
and my parents have separate bedrooms
and they love life I didn't know I'm
using it I'm using it as a metaphor for
you know if you can do it you know get
your own room sleep is key to recovery
and health so true so now let's
translate that into the political
situation in the United States maybe
it's we're supposed to actually have
these states for a reason where
the federal government should not be
banning like these like weapons and guns
and restricting them if you live in West
Virginia and you want a hundred round
drum fully auto that's that's on you
just you know I mention this all the
time people drive cars all day every day
and they're not ramming me or chasing me
down I do not fear them I see a guy
driving a car I don't think twice I saw
a guy walking on the street in West
Virginia with a crossbow I didn't go oh
he's got a crossbow oh no what do I do I
just went howdy hey that's it I don't
know like am I supposed to be worried
the guy's armed no someone in the car
could run me over but for some reason at
the federal level they're like we've
everybody decided that everyone in this
country can no longer have this or that
because we are scared now there's a
reason for States and we should probably
start upholding that maybe that would
solve a lot of these problems in
Maryland you might be worried about the
person driving toward you in a car and
why is that what it's like Maryland
drivers are kind of notorious for for
bad driving well I just mean look when I
see cars I get out of the way I don't
just stand there and think the scars
barreling towards me I'm no you you look
both ways when you cross the street but
cars can kill you someone in the car can
choose to use it as a weapon of a a
lethal weapon and they don't do it and
there have been cases where sure it's
not a daily occurrence yeah right and
there's occasions where people take guns
and do bad things with them but I just
look at it like the average person
wielding a lethal force does not use it
that's it so I'm not worried about
people having guns but anyway the main
reason I bring that up is just that the
problem we're facing this country is
that if there is going to be a national
divorce it's going to be because no one
will let States be or should say it's
because the Democrat big cities will not
let everyone else just be that's usually
the reason I think historically if
someone succeeds it's because they're
getting smacked down by the person
that's trying to control them right and
if they just backed off then we'd we'd
Let It Go we'd be like yeah you know
it's it's kind of bad but we're okay but
now it's just too bad there are some
things like pollution regulations that I
understand the federal government's got
to get annoying about because like you
don't if you're burning a lot or dumping
stuff in the water and it goes into
another state then
you know then someone else an Arbiter
needs to come in and kind of smooth
things over
or or you know take control even
sometimes which is little or force you
to control yourself from a different
perspective that's what the government
does Ian that's what they do with
Monsanto that's what they do with all
these other multinational corporations
they just give them permission slips to
poison and to to release their
pollutants everywhere else that's that's
essentially what government's doing in
since like uh since when since the
central banks in 1830 like since the
early adoption I don't know when you
want to go back but but when you look at
what the government's doing they're
essentially one of the biggest and
largest polluters on the world and the
biggest enablers are pollute pollution
on the world uh and a lot of their
policies are absolutely nonsensical and
leading to the destruction of our planet
when it comes to destroying the national
resources and and just sending it off to
China to to to to let them uh pollute
even more because we can't you know
handle all our own trash here it's
absolutely ridiculous what if we removed
the human element from politics and had
a computer do it all right coming soon
coming soon have a computer do some of
it some advice maybe I mean that's
probably already happening and it's
probably gonna be miserable the robot's
gonna be like humans like corn make more
corn and then you're gonna be like okay
I guess we're making corn and then just
humans do like corn man and they're
gonna make a whole lot of it Bill Gates
likes corn apparently yeah and soy he
really loves soy as you can see from his
you know yeah absolutely his boobs boobs
yep his moves technical term yeah I
don't think humans are going to create
an AI that is like humans are going to
create an AI they think is good enough
to run the show but it's not going to be
good enough to run the show and then
it's just gonna make a mess of
everything yeah humans got to govern
themselves uh but having machines advise
us like intelligent machines can always
give advice because they can do
calculations really quick and be like
well if you if you put the factory there
you will create this amount of pollution
in these places with this amount of wind
current but if the wind current's
different give you all these different
contingent possibilities
let's jump to this story from the Daily
Mail
oregonians Force vote to secede from the
woke State and become part of Idaho two
counties are set to vote on the measure
after nine backed it due to defund the
police critical race theory in schools
and bail laws before we get to the point
where states secede from the union
before we get to the point where anyone
is trying to engage in a civil war the
first that's happening is in Oregon
they're not trying to leave the union
they're trying to move a portion of the
state into a different state I don't
know if they have a picture of the of
the whole there you go look at this
greater Idaho hey I'm all for it man I
think it's exactly what needs to happen
hell yeah so uh Portland can they can
they can have their weird urban center
in fact this is what should happen
across the board every major city you
can just be your own every major city
becomes its own uh city-state State yeah
back to city and what happens is the
Democrats end up with like 12 senators
and Republicans end up with you know 60.
right and so that's sort of the thing is
you have so many states where there are
these large Urban centers that control
everything and have and have the biggest
population that are left-wing and then
all of the rest of the state which
encompasses a much bigger land mass but
has fewer people rural much more
conservative and they get out voted in a
lot of kids I mean even a state like
Maryland which is pretty democratic
you don't have Baltimore you don't have
Prince George's County Montgomery County
where all the government employees live
it's Maga country it's it's Maga country
yeah right now we're in Maryland and
it's Maga country New York these Three
Counties issued a letter saying they
wanted to secede and join West Virginia
hmm yeah wow there you go
the problem is this stuff isn't
happening and it needs to happen the the
shift the votes should be very easy it
prevents in destabilization it prevents
Civil War if greater Idaho happened
there would be people would feel
satiated they'd feel satisfied they'd
feel like their voices were heard and
this makes sense for them and they
wouldn't be part of a state that was
abusive towards them instead what's
happening is greater Idaho you have
these nine counties and they're saying
like hey we shouldn't be here and
they're like shut your mouths well what
do you think that leads to secession
usually yeah eventually they're gonna be
back then we're out we're just grumbling
and conflict grumbling acceptance but I
mean what would this do this would if
this did happen it would cut back on the
amount of votes that Oregon would no uh
well yeah Oregon would lose votes Idaho
would gain votes in Congress but
Senators would stay the same so they're
not even trying to make their own state
they're trying to just become part of a
different one there's a similar thing
happening in Northern Colorado Northern
California the state of Jefferson
Northern California and that that should
happen I think so new States hey you
know we don't need 50 states forever I
know it's a nice round number but let's
just split up make them smaller I think
that might be kind of neat there will
always be a certain number of people
though who will they live in Portland
and they'll see this new expanded Idaho
and they'll say oh that looks really
nice I want to live there and then they
go live there and they say I actually
want to vote though for all the policies
I had in Portland then they don't make
any association between the policies and
why Portland was bad and Idaho is good
look there's a video from Ami Horowitz
and prageru
and he walks up to people and he's
asking them to I think sign a petition
uh to allow a five-year-old to undergo a
sex change operation
and in one of the conversations this
woman goes I completely agree with this
and then he's like yeah you know
five-year-old kids can make their own
decisions they know what's right for
their body because I agree thank you so
much for doing this and it's like
conservatives think this is a gotcha
like they're exposing it these people
genuinely believe this stuff there's
you're not like waking them up to make
them realize they're wrong they're
saying like no I agree I I believe this
and you're like aha I've exposed you and
they're like no I talk about this all
the time we we have child drag shows we
do this all the time you're not you're
you what happens is conservatives can't
believe that the average person would
support this and then when they talk to
these people and hear them saying they
support they're like look look everybody
this person supports it and then all of
the the body snatcher people turn slowly
and look at you and go because they all
agree with it they're all on board with
it there there is a there's an
ideological fracture in this country I
ain't being mended
so maybe greater Idaho needs to happen
huh yeah I think it does I think Western
uh Maryland needs to break off and
become part of West Virginia
it definitely makes more sense but I I
think a lot of bureaucrats want their
tax cattle to stay because they want to
treat them like cattle and they want to
of course siphon off all the money and
wealth that they can from them to
finance their Insanity because if the
people leave who's going to finance a
lot of this Insanity as of course a lot
of the people are in the rural areas uh
usually are independent usually are
people working for themselves usually or
people who are successful and
um yeah you know they want that money so
I don't see this happening yeah or
Oregon's not going to let you tax cataly
call them yeah slaves yeah pretty much
you get nothing you can't do anything
about it and we get money from you why
would you why would we let you leave
what do we gain from it yeah and we get
to impose any kind of policies we want
on you so what's the incentive of
Portland letting them go is there is
there any incentive uh Portland would
get their their voting ideology more
prominent in State Legislature
just I just want everybody in in uh
Eastern Idaho to realize
your life is being dictated to by a
bunch of 20 year old lunatics who've not
had jobs running around Portland
smashing things and starting fires
so when you're say working on a farm
working hard every day to provide for
your family to produce food and crops
that human beings need
your life is controlled by a crackpot 20
year old white leftist who weighs 110
pounds soaking wet running around going
America is racist and then screaming
racial slurs at black cops because
they're apparently the The Virtuous ones
and then setting fires and fire bombing
buildings and law enforcement won't
arrest them and then they go and vote
and the politics pen to them and they
are in charge of you congratulations
so I don't blame him for wanting to vote
to leave the problem is the system
doesn't allow it like it's become too
rigid like you were saying earlier when
it comes to the Constitution all of
these things like the age you have to be
we were very serious about this but the
actual enumerated powers that's
how what do we do what do we do do we
just sit back and wait until the whole
thing explodes we're not supposed to
we're supposed to change it as we go
that's very very intentional Convention
of States new Amendment a path towards
shifting borders of states very easily
it should be extremely easy for this to
happen not ridiculously hard granted
I don't understand why Oregon as a state
should have a voting right over a county
that votes to leave why would that be
well I didn't have no disruption the
taxes yeah it would be too bad like
imagine if if you know you know uh you
you have a roommate and then I say well
look it's my house and I've determined
you're not allowed to leave you got to
keep paying rent you'd be like not later
you walk out the door right it's gone
for imagine if the police said well hold
on the guy who owns the house has said
you're not allowed to do that so we're
under arrest and we're bringing you back
that's insane it makes no sense it would
be more like if I'm like no this room
that I'm renting from you is my house
now or I'd be like no this room I'm
renting in your house belongs to your
neighbor you'd be like no it's my room
well I suppose it's a little different
because we're talking about a space
that's very far away and not occupied by
a person so how about a garage
let's say that uh you own the garage
and uh it's I I don't I don't know how
that would actually work because if
people own the land they're on you know
what I mean it can be like a good point
yeah but the landowners should be able
to decide what state they're a part of
right they should and then they all vote
as their County and if the County votes
why should Oregon why should Portland be
able to be like nah you can't leave and
what would their mechanism really be at
that point now obviously we can think of
some pretty horrible things that would
be their mechanism but I don't think
that would be
the first thing out of the gate that
would happen so there'd be lawsuits but
they have no police they can't enforce
any laws
Eastern Idaho if they vote for this and
then decide it is it is period Portland
can that the Oregon government can be
like we do not recognize the secession
of Eastern Oregon and they can be like
what are you going to do about it what
are you gonna do you're gonna go to
every single County and every single
family and then occupy their
neighborhoods at gunpoint never going to
happen if the confidence of the people
of Greater Idaho of the people of
Eastern Oregon is that we do not
recognize the state of Oregon anymore
there is literally nothing anyone can do
to stop them it would be like a civil
disobedient act they would say we're not
paying taxes to the state of uh Oregon
anymore we're paying them to the state
of Idaho and then Oregon would be like
no pay us your taxes they're like well
we're idahoan now and then the Idaho
would send out the National Guard if
they if it escalated the Idaho's put the
National Guard in the new territory if
Idaho accepted it yeah yeah and then say
this is our state but what I'm saying is
let's say Idaho says look we don't want
to get involved in this
or again as a state then says these
regions aren't allowed to secede but you
can look on the map where you can see
all of the areas that have voted in
favor of joining Idaho I mean it's it's
there it's like almost the entirety of
Eastern Oregon if they all if all the
people there simply said my government
is you know this person if if these
people these counties all have their
County Commissioners or whatever and
they say
the laws that I follow come from the
County Commission are not from a state
we don't recognize Oregon can do nothing
the feds can do nothing the feds cannot
go people need to understand this there
are not enough federal agents to
actually go into an entire State and
enforce the law they would have to
occupy every city Corner they would have
to go door to door they would have to
arrest everyone it will never happen
that's only if the majority of these
people stop abiding by state government
and decide they're their own State the
feds have no choice but to recognize it
otherwise there's just nothing that you
can't do anything about it
it's that's just it
you were saying something before and I
cut you off I'm sorry about that I would
just tend to think that the in Oregon or
any place like that the tax enforcement
authorities would be the last police
that would be defunded those would be
fully funded so Civil Disobedience acts
by not paying taxes I think they do have
a response to uh but what I mean is if
every single person there just stopped
abiding they couldn't do anything about
it I mean by all means go ahead and
arrest every single citizen of this
County it's just not going to happen
it's a form of implosion it would just
destroy well there's not enough Law
Enforcement Officers look in New York
City I think there's what like 40 000
cops is that is that the number Luke I
think 30 000. yeah tens of thousands
tens of thousands out of out of a city
with with uh with what nine million in
its City in City borders nine million
people if nine million people in New
York just stopped paying their taxes
what are the cops gonna do about it so
is that not something I'm advocating for
I'm saying if that were to occur that
the government can't do anything it's
the government exists due to the
confidence of the people if the people
believe the government has the authority
or is Justified then they follow along
but if these people are voting to say
we're no longer part of Oregon we're
getting to that point where they're
going to say Oregon you do not represent
us like imagine if you know California
tried passing this bill I don't know if
they did where they can tax someone 10
years after they leave the state did you
guys hear about this one yes imagine
you're living in Texas and California
knocks on your door and says yours taxes
you'd be like get out I don't live in
California go away what gives you the
right that's how people here are going
to feel
so New York City has 36 000 police
officers and 19 000 civilian employees
so right that's you know 36 000 officers
think about how small that number is oh
it sounds big 36 000. how many people
are in the New York Metro you want to
look it up is it 12 million I think it's
like 9.5 or something I thought it was
18 is it nine well in in the in the
Metro you've got other police outside of
that so let's just say City proper in
the in the in the in the city proper
jurisdiction what's the population 20
million in the city yeah no New York
metropolitan area population the Metro
includes like Jersey City and and things
outside of New York yeah yeah yeah so
City population proper I think is like
nine or something
I mean I can I can pull it up I'm
looking at it let's let's get it let's
get it NYC let's look up the uh the
official City 8.4 million eight point as
of 2013 it was 8.4 8.8 as of 2020. I got
it here from Wikipedia April 1st 8.8
million that's wow that went down
yeah man crazy I'm pretty sure it was
higher than that before but whatever
yeah it's it's in Decline
so 8.8 million people
if let's say uh one percent of the
population of New York just uh let's say
they got infected they got zombie virus
that right on the running round the 88
000 people there's not nearly enough
police officers to deal with that one
percent if one percent now let's go back
in time and let's let's go back to a
time when New York had 100 people living
in it
if one percent went nuts no problem one
guy one guy running around they just
they just tie them up
then you get to the point where there's
a million and one percent now you've got
thousands and that's getting much much
more difficult to deal with with 8.8
million people
one percent of the population outright
just going out and saying you know hey
we're gonna Riot the police can do
literally nothing and that's why in 2020
the police could do literally nothing
too many people write it overwhelm the
police force doesn't work so what do you
do I'm open to new ideas you know the
United States is um an experiment it's
one of the most experimental governments
maybe to ever have been tried well I
don't know if that's I can't claim that
but it's it's government is experimental
and to think that we could split up
States and move them around and move
around counties that's fascinating and
it could be fantastic for for
communication and for the peaceful you
know settlement
let's let's let's talk about the New
York Metro 20 million the New York Metro
is 20 million so this includes uh just
north of what is it like Westchester and
like Jersey City and Union City in Long
Island a little bit dirty Jersey I think
dirty Jersey and all that stuff Bayonne
or whatever
20 million people
if one percent
wow
if one percent of that
everything are we looking at is that
that's that's uh 200 000 people
if if one percent of the New York Metro
went into Manhattan in a rage 200 000
people running through the streets
smashing and riding the police would be
on the first boat helicopter or car out
of the city and say I ain't dealing with
this you saw it possible did you see
what happened during the black lives
matter protest a lot of them were like
oh yeah we're just gonna I'm not gonna
do anything we're just gonna sit back
and stand back that's that's what I've
talked about the the the more massive
the population you need a massive number
of law enforcement to deal with it
imagine if one percent of New York
citizens were just like we are no longer
complying with government the police
would be unable to do anything about it
and that's literally what's happening
mind you the reason crime is
skyrocketing did you guys see this uh
brawl Mart video they're calling it yes
people in Walmart they're just fighting
like crazy the reason why people tended
not to fight is like I don't want to get
arrested like you know I I get it now no
one is getting arrested they know
they're not getting arrested so they're
like what do I care
now you've got a dude Buck Naked running
around the Subways of New York New York
Subway City uh New York City subway
killings are our 25-year High yeah
people being pushed onto the tracks
young women being murdered because they
know they're not getting arrested they
do the police cannot deal with it so
it's a Cascade effect
when 36 000 cops
can deal with the crime and people
believe the police can deal with the
crime crimes is lower because people are
worried criminals are like you got to be
careful the cops will get you now that
confidence is being shattered it's going
to create a snowball rolling down a hill
effect where more and more criminals are
like cops aren't going to do anything
yeah this is why according to some
estimates ridership in the New York City
uh subway system is down significantly
because a lot of people are afraid to go
on the New York City subway system it's
also one of the main reasons why people
are fleeing New York City and escaping a
lot of these failed policies that were
implemented and of course bought for by
George Soros that of course planted a
whole bunch of District Attorneys and
woke individuals into governments that
of course are pushing policies that are
absolutely nonsensical obviously there's
a legitimate conversation to have about
Criminal Justice Reform yes but when you
have that same Criminal Justice Reform
being turned to punish people for
political thoughts and ideas when you
have the the Manhattan district attorney
focusing on Donald Trump as violence is
engulfing that entire city there there
should be someone saying hey you should
get your priorities straight hey we
shouldn't be letting criminals off into
the streets that are extremely violent
that are going to be hurting people
maybe we should stop focusing on
punishing people for their political
ideas and maybe we should actually start
serving and protecting the the
population of the country this is really
cool check this out this is the uh a map
of the New York metropolitan area
so you can see that you've got you know
like New York down here but it goes up
to Putnam it goes up to Pike County
Sussex more so it's massive stuff like
all of Long Island is basically included
in it
this is
it's massive and just put it simply and
I I don't know we know there's 36 000
police in New York City proper for eight
million people I wonder what the total
police population of the entire New York
Metro would be I would imagine it's not
relative uh it it doesn't scale the
amount of police you need in like
Somerset is substantially less per per
person per capita than you would need in
a very dense New York city so my view is
going to be it's 50 000 for the entire
metro Maybe
yeah but but you know at least we're
gonna have 87 000 IRS agents according
to the inflation reduction act that was
of course promptly promoted by Bill
Gates who's openly bragging how he was
the one that came forward with this bill
so who cares about real law enforcement
you could have IRS agents walking around
armed with guns they just got to do the
robot stealing your money the dog drones
you know what I mean so so when you act
a fool the Drone flies to your house and
then it dispatches the little dog guy
with the gun on his back in it
citizen you have violated the law and
then you're like ah crap
ever punched a dog
um no yeah me neither I think that
you're right a metal one that it's it
doesn't scale like plus the streets are
too small so like even if you had 10
times the cops they couldn't even fit to
stop the crowd so this is why they're
going into anti-terrorism laws they want
Strategic Defense against this kind of
stuff they look for like ring leaders
they want to take it out at the source
so that big crowds don't proliferate and
drones I'm very concerned about the use
of mechanical drones in oh yeah police
defense like they're doing in China they
literally quadcoptered in a Boston
Dynamic it wasn't a Boston Dynamic robot
but it was a similar model like that the
dog with a with a gun on its back and
the Drone drops it yeah it like that's
one way really small drone police force
it's terrifying though because it can be
co-opted and hacked and stuff Terminator
scenario could very well happen and I
know like in the movie it's this it's
his fanciful AI that like I guess Skynet
declares war on Humanity or whatever
robots fight humans it could be
something as simple as we program robots
for law enforcement
we give them specific parameters but
humans are imperfect and the programming
is imperfect and then all of a sudden
all of the robo dogs think they're
enforcing the law perfectly and they're
just targeting anyone it could be as
simple as this right I'll give you an
example I talk about this doc the Doctor
Who episode where they go to this planet
everyone's dead and there are robots
that have these screens and smiley faces
and what they discover is that the
robots were programmed to keep people
happy
when some when an old woman died a
member of The Colony everybody got sad
the robots tried as hard as they could
to make people happy but it wasn't
working
then they found that if a sad person
came into contact with a happy person
the happy person became sad why sad
person told him old person died the
robots then started to view sadness as a
contagion and decided for the sake of
happiness it had to kill anyone who was
spreading negativity like a virus of
course that made everybody freak out and
very very unhappy to the point where
they just killed everyone that's a good
example of what happens we'll make these
robots and be like assist law
enforcement the robot drone will be like
detainment protocol suspicious activity
it'll approach a person and they'll be
like yo get that dog away from me then
it'll be like suspect is fleeing suspect
is fleeing deploy countermeasures this
causes the person to get tased trip fall
hit his head and die a bunch of people
in the area then go that thing just
killed that person for no reason they'll
start screaming and now they now the
robot robot goes assisting a criminal
assisting criminal all of these people
are now targets and then all of a sudden
the robo dogs are attacking every random
person and the AI runs amok we think
we're beyond that but these things can
happen because humans who program this
these machines are fallible and of
course the programming will be as well
and then before you know it you'll have
that other Black Mirror episode where
the robo dogs are going around hunting
people and what was it like Amazon was
delivering things that they didn't want
to them the AI was just giving them
things
man that was a crazy episode I don't
remember that part of it there were robo
dogs like patrolling and there was a
factory that just mass produced goods
for humans and there was like a
resistance and then and then it turns
out that the humans were already extinct
and that the people who you thought were
humans were actually robots created by
the AI gosh because the AI needed humans
to fulfill its purpose of delivering
Goods oh good it is so crazy yeah the
the robots will be networked and I think
it's important to not start calling them
dogs keep always remember these things
are robots they're not animals
um and so keep that in mind don't get
tricked into speaking their language and
they're going on networks and networks
can be hacked and viruses can cause
things to malfunction but but you know
look Ian like you gotta admit
everybody's got like the part of you
knows how exciting it would be to like
live in a post
post-apocalyptic world where you have
like a baseball bat on your back and
you're foraging for food and then the
robot comes and then you get into this
epic video game like battle fighting
with the robot at least that's what
people probably assume until they
actually get into a life or death
situation adrenaline kicks in and
they're begging for begging for safety
and say a savior to come you know it's
funny when people think uh there's a
there's an old joke my friend posted a
long time ago he said I want and
encourage a zombie apocalypse and it's
like people actually have fantasies
about being in the scenario and then
it's just like man anyone who's ever
been in a real life or death situation
is going to tell you that you really
really don't want anything like that no
way nope have you been close to stuff
like that Serge
a few times in my life yeah
unfortunately just being in South Africa
it's kind of uh the nature of it and
also living in La for the last three
years just kind of puts you up against
whether you like it or not what'd you
notice in La did you uh the change in
the city the last three years
uh I say if you're everyone living in LA
right now can definitely say that after
the pandemic after 2020 things
definitely got a lot worse uh you kind
of have to remember La before you know
the pandemic started or I guess it's
just a lockdown started the before times
yeah the before times I've literally
said that before
um but it kind of just hit the fan more
so than I already was hitting the fan
and it seems like to me it's almost
unrecoverable at this point I don't want
to say that it is but it definitely
seems that way well I agree it's a
snowball rolling down a hill what was
crazier South Africa or LA
that is a great question I kind of
realized when I was hearing about
carjackings uh home invasions uh people
just being mugged on the street for
their money and their jewelry and Etc
that I was like all right my parents
brought me to this country to take me
away from that it's time for me to like
you know make my next moves
oh that was the stuff that was going on
in South Africa yeah uh that was going
on South Africa yes but uh when I
started seeing that in LA and living
there in LA I was like okay this is this
is time for me to start just like
debating my next moves because just it's
not what I it's not what I'm here for
you know it's not what I want to be
around you know so yeah it's definitely
gone worse since the pandemic I bet
anyone else in the chat can rip and yeah
gotta get away man gotta get out of
those cities all right we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends be the
notification you want to see in the
world we are being censored we're
hearing it from many people so share the
video and also become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only uncensored show coming up at about
11 p.m but for now we will read your
super chats here we go ferret man he
says since you plan on playing cartoons
at freedomastan one that I recommend is
a Netflix series oddballs by YouTube
animator
Theo is at fiad D Stout
Fiat Fiat is out I don't know what that
means not only is it great for all ages
but it has subtle anti-wokism episode 8
villain is clearly fouchy really it's on
Netflix called oddballs and the villain
is fauci
you want to write that one down
huh well we'll see if I I'll send you a
trailer of it Netflix series oddballs
episode 8 villain is fauci wouldn't
surprise me at that yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr's in the chat he
says Tim it's great to see folks wake up
to the Grift that is AOC Spirit fingers
then the cult pledge at um Medical
School the fight will be long grueling
but Victory is in our sights for the
line less than 25 days now to vote these
people out do you guys see the
University of I think it was it
Minnesota
where they're all chanting mindlessly
about supporting indigenous medicine and
Health Equity and stopping white
supremacy
yeah this is cult stuff dude I did not
see that very very creepy man
Alex megiori says I probably pronounce
your name wrong on your 4 pm show you
said keeping gas low is to help with
midterms but I disagree I think they're
trying to keep it low long enough for
Republicans to take control to salvage
the 2024 election I don't know what you
mean by that I don't understand how that
would that would work
all right
KPTM uh Captain Marvel oh that's what it
is Tim I know Bill Gates is the move
Master but you should check out
Microsoft's open source election guard
Tech it's a way of cryptographically
verifying the Integrity of election
results really is that true
5420 USD Super Chat well interesting
rocket saw says Tim got the notification
today however today my feed has been
inundated with timcast IRL segments from
two years ago algorithm has clearly
changed interesting I wonder why that is
I wonder why yeah
maybe they want to make sure people
don't watch our modern episodes during
the midterm and then you only get
outdated information that won't help you
there you go
pop Shepherd says did you see the Gaff
CNN weather's Twitter liked uh not safe
for work abdl tweet today it was weird
was up for three hours took screenshots
and everything what is that abdl
I don't know what that is no idea let's
just say it was not here
Triton says Luke thank you for sharing
Johnny's story I'll raise my glass to
this young man though you may have lived
as a man for only a few short months
your final moments showed the courage of
a hundred men's lifetimes cheers mate
yeah Johnny's an incredible you know
human being he deserves to be remembered
and his story is just absolutely insane
again he saved a lot of people from a
mass shooter he he he's a hero without a
doubt and then what happened the police
responded the police officer even though
he didn't meet the description of the
shooter even though he was he bent down
he he took down the the mass shooter he
took away his firearm he went to a
corner and he was kneeling down in the
corner taking uh the magazine and
bullets out of the of the gun he wasn't
pointing it to anyone an officer opened
the door and behind the door shot six
times shot him once in the butt and then
they let him bleed out for 40 minutes
and they didn't call and they didn't the
EMTs didn't get him in over 40 minutes
as he bled out and died as he stopped a
mass shooting in uh in Colorado it's
absolutely disgusting I was just there
uh in Colorado I talked to his friends I
talked to his family members I released
a YouTube video it's on the YouTube
channel right now we are change
Murph tries DIY says if Trump was
elected as house Speaker would that give
him a better understanding of the rot
inside the administrative state
perhaps a lot of people I mentioned this
earlier that uh if Trump if if they
impeach Biden people are like oh but
then Kamala Harris becomes president and
then it's like what if he what if
they're both impeached well then it's
Nancy Pelosi it's like no no any kind of
impeachment will only come after
Republicans take the house in which
Kevin McCarthy would probably be speaker
if the house then impeaches Biden over
this quid pro quo and Harris
then you'd need a conviction which is
not going to happen but let's just say
it does then you'd get a Republican
president
I I think they absolutely should
nominate Trump to be speaker
of the house the Republicans wouldn't do
it though because Republicans are
terrible it'd be fun though wouldn't it
Speaker of the House Donald Trump does
he have to be in the senate for that to
occur it's Congress but in the house he
doesn't have to no so they can they can
choose anybody but they typically just
pick somebody who's in in the house
yep I think that'd be great camel of the
Mojave says on this show they blame
corrupt politicians and corrupt private
businesses and the answer is the corrupt
people voting for Endless Warfare on
this show how much I understand
the answer is the corrupt people are you
saying all the people are corrupt I
don't think they are I think there are
corrupt people in which they have to
hope that there's more not corrupt
people who are voting against it
there you go
all right let's see what we got here
let's grab uh let's grab another Super
Chat
Mike Giovanni says pronounced nuclear
correctly Luke no don't tell me what to
do a lot of people are pointing out that
uh Drew Miller is on the show he's a PhD
in nuclear bet wartime nuclear you kept
saying nuclear and people were like he's
got a PhD in this stuff like he's saying
nuclear maybe we have it right and
everyone else has it wrong nuclear where
does that word even come from I never
understood that I don't know yeah I
think Bush was saying it for a while
back nuclear nuclear my parents would
always hate that yeah huh it's new clear
new clear that's pronounced
Kaiser C says I just had to put my
little buddy Tanner a cat down an hour
and a half ago he doesn't have to suffer
anymore thanks guys you make life more
bearable despite the sad parts of it
sorry to hear man these things are uh
are a part of life but uh you got to
have a good little buddy Tanner for a
long time Tanner yeah we got bogus I
think bocus is going on three or four
years old I think he's maybe he might be
four
and he's out doing Boca stuff he's a cat
he's just outside chilling looking smug
so cats do yeah thank him for being cool
he's a little terrorist I don't like him
he just killed him he just killed a
squirrel there's a poor squirrel
downstairs again yes he loves eating
blood all over himself and then he tries
to go on the kitchen counter oh no yes
I'm like no he goes into the skate ramps
because nobody can get him and then he
just sits there for hours eating
squirrel money and the squirrels are
like compared to him they're like a
third of his size or maybe like a fourth
so he's like carrying this squirrel in
his mouth just trotting along all proud
of himself I'm proud of him because for
a while he was going after baby rabbits
and it's like come on dude be a man
that's a much more sympathetic victim
too as a baby rabbit baby come on it's
like imagine a dude like this ripped 220
pound Hunter guy going like I'm going
hunting for baby deer what that's not
impressive that's sad give me a buck a
big win you know win victory in your
hunt and feed the family not just
killing babies you're supposed to let
the babies grow up that's why it was
like we all made fun of him maybe maybe
boca's got the message when we were
mocking him for killing a baby rabbit
and he and he he graduated to adult
squirrels okay that's more acceptable
those are bigger half in the chat for
Tanner though yeah
[Music]
Carrie green says had Twitter for less
than 90 days been banned again for
making fun of VP Harris's ability to
drive a stick shift you guys are awesome
keep up the good work yeah that's how
they do it huh maybe Elon Musk will
actually uh actually take over at some
point
and then this will all be uh just a
horrible nightmare in the past
let's grab another Super Chat aoc's
birthday today she's took 33 iOS from
reading so birthday today happy birthday
Alex wow happy birthday ocasio-cortez
David H says what are the odds that
zelenski has dirt on the bidens and
that's why the US is giving Ukraine so
much money and support I think
there's a probability that's for sure
a lot of people you know a lot of people
are spreading these memes it's really
funny they claim AOC is super rich and
they claim Tulsi gabbard is too and I
should never understood that yeah there
was a thing that went around saying that
her net worth uh Cortez's net worth of
22 million and then she responded to her
she's like dude I still have student
loans yeah
yeah it's just weird it's like I'm sure
she's she's making good money now she's
probably making more money than you
realize but come on 22 million and then
there's a meme going around saying Tulsi
gabbard owns a 10 billion 10 million
dollar mansion and a 400 000 car and I'm
like I just don't really believe that
fake news yeah don't believe everything
you read those websites where it's like
they tell you someone's net worth those
are all fake they'll be like you know
one of them said Ian was worth like five
million dollars 12. it's a 12. 12 and
then the next next week it was 1.2 and
then it was like I don't know 12 million
yeah I don't know unless Ian's secretly
lying well I have stock in Minds that
which is worth I don't know what mines
is calculated at it's a private company
so there you go that's probably worth a
lot Ian's a secret billionaire billions
billions
the judge says gas was 159 a gallon the
week of the presidential election wow
jeez that's crazy those were the days
man those were the days
all right beep boop says Tim if you're
looking for a good new show you should
you should watch Arcane I say this
because you're constantly saying there's
no new good shows am I saying that I
just finished watching Better Call Saul
that wrapped up the last season this
year and uh I give the whole series a 10
out of 10. but the ending really it was
like yeah I guess did it feel forced no
it felt like nothing don't spoil it okay
you're watching it yeah the ending I
just I just was on I I was on I was
unenthused I was like oh are you okay
whatever I'm in YouTube clip phase on
that one you know I that's pretty much
how I do most TV now is I I sample it on
YouTube if I watch enough Clips I say
okay maybe that's worth watching the
series and then I watch the whole series
in like a weekend just binge YouTube
shorts you mean I usually watch like
YouTube shorts yeah that's right oh I
watched She-Hulk I I can now
definitively say with the finale out it
is possibly one of the worst shows I
have ever seen and I am going to spoil
oil it for you because I hate it that
much and I have no respect for the show
there's no season finale
the last episode breaks down into okay
there's an AOC scene seriously She-Hulk
there's a scene where this woman okay so
a bunch of dudes misogynists are
trolling She-Hulk because women I guess
and so someone to bake them
the friend of Shield posts Shield
dancing in college and she's wearing
thick black glasses with her hair down
and it's very obviously an AOC thing and
that's like and they're like Suk phone
and then for some reason
the Hulk is there the abomination's
fighting Titania is fighting and then
Shield just looks at the camera and says
this is a really stupid story it makes
no sense and then she and then it cuts
to a fake picture of the of the Disney
plus streaming menu and she punches
through it I'm not kidding and she goes
ah here we go and jumps into a different
movie and then for the next 50 minutes
it's her walking around Marvel Studios
in real life and then she meets Kevin
feige who's actually an AI and she just
says the story is bad and he says okay
and then she goes back to the story and
the story is over yeah she goes back and
it's like that's the end of the story
and she's like there we go and for all
like I was just like what I call that
the Greeks we're called deus ex machina
where oh but the very end of a movie
there's some god-like creature just
appears and tells you it was all a dream
and everything's solved now I mean well
deus ex machina uh what does it mean the
god from the machine yeah yeah or got in
the machine it basically means that as
the writer of the show you can you can
make anything happen and so deus ex
machina is then like oh uh Superman he
died but he's alive now because a meteor
came and it it reignited his Kryptonian
blood and he's alive so uh this was
worse than that this was like I know
let's end this show by not concluding
any elements of the story resolving none
of the lingering issues and telling you
outright it doesn't matter you will
never know and it was all one big waste
of your time yeah such lazy writing if
anyone wants to watch uh sing shots out
what's his name uh it's a Gundam forget
his name you'll know that guy he's done
that serious right gone on it for the
last while now She-Hulk it's a Gundam is
the guy's name uh I think so I took
something like that I just know Gundam
is like his title on YouTube that
everyone refers to him as all right I
see redesign says Rick Santorum oh no we
can't impeach him
okay well uh Rick came on the show and
uh it was great to have him you know
people are a lot of disagree and
he said we shouldn't impeach Joe Biden
because he should only be impeached for
things he's done while President not for
past things well now we got it we got a
quid pro quo so they should impeach him
all right the moment they win they come
in on what January 3rd or something they
should immediately be like okay articles
of impeachment all in favor there you go
vote do it he should be impeached over
this I am not confident Republicans will
do it because while you'll get Marjorie
Taylor green for sure and many
Republicans will sign on you're gonna
get another half we're going to be like
no come on guys you know we have to be
above all this and the Democrats will
reject it and then there will be a
majority in opposition to impeaching Joe
Biden
welcome to the modern era
dracona Force says the NFL just aired a
commercial about election day and how
important it is to get educated and let
your voice be heard I'm sure they hit
the demographic they were looking for
here
I mean what if they're getting a bunch
of who was the kind of person who likes
football they're probably more likely to
vote for Trump right yeah so good
whatever I don't know I I think though
one of the ads said that if you vote in
this election it will decide all of the
issues that matter most to you so this
was clearly has to be the person who
wrote the sad's very first election if
they believe that
all right Travis Tolbert says Tim Trump
literally threatened to drop
thermonuclear bombs on Moscow and
Beijing your stance is tantamount to
opposing World War II Lend Lease that
kept our allies from falling to the Nazi
regime I actually criticized Trump
threatening nuclear weapons saying it's
really bad but at the very least the the
fear of Donald Trump actually prevented
the escalation of War so it's like
you know is it perfect no is it good
it's kind of not that good that Trump
had this Behavior about him but uh it's
certainly better than Joe Biden and the
Democrats or whatever and many
Republicans
getting the US involved in a border
dispute with Russia and Ukraine that
could result in World War III I just
don't see the reason for it
I I don't get it yeah the lend lease
program was after the Nazis had
conquered Paris it was very overtly that
they were attempting to take over the
world
alcas SB says Tim bring elad aliyahu to
debate with Luke about Ukraine
oh yeah have you met a lot yet no oh we
got it we got to do that a lot we got
we'll have you back on so you can debate
with Luke it'll be the the loudest and
most raucous show we've ever had so when
we so what's the stance he believes in
an American unipolar world that the
United States should be expanding and
and actively actively the World Police
to prevent a multi-polar world which
would be more dangerous and so when we
were arguing about war he's very much in
favor of U.S operations and expansion
and all that stuff okay I was getting I
got triggered I got so mad I I I I think
we should have Cassandra here as well
too yeah Cassandra would be great I I
would prefer Cassandra and this other
guy dude
herself uh just by herself she's a she's
a very strong uh woman uh who I think
could handle the conversation a lot
better than I can but with that being
said A lot's fantastic he does ground
field reporting for us on the ground
he's really really great and I actually
respect that we can have these arguments
and I got really mad and I apologize for
getting super mad but it's cool that we
can have those conversations absolutely
keep working together yeah but I just
you know War yeah I I just don't believe
we need War to stop war that doesn't
make any rational sense to me I got
pushed back on that I mean people say
fighting fire with fire when they do
controlled Burns they'll burn a strip of
like if there's no fire why in the world
do you need fire to stop the fire that
doesn't make any sense and I think
essentially that that's the core of the
argument for War I just think the issue
is as a farm and there's a small farm
next to it and they're fighting and so
we're two miles two three miles away and
you were like I know let's bring weapons
to one of those farms for some reason
and it's like why dude like neighbors
are fighting let's not be involved in
that you know what and world war three
great great that's what I want no no
thank you
all right Andrew says don't
underestimate Joe Biden's ability to F
things up Obama apparently that's right
yep
quote all right
comment uh commandther says question for
Ian are you excited for Victoria three
um I have Crusader Kings 2 I think this
Paradox game I haven't gotten into
Victoria series or the uh Universe
Europa Universe Alice which I also have
but I was looking at some gameplay
footage of it it looks pretty cool it's
very diplomatic
which uh
it's pretty cool I like the Conquering
aspect of Crusader Kings I guess short
answer is no but I'm gonna keep my eyes
on it thank you
all right Tim Jake says Luke are you
saying the Coalition would not have
liberated Kuwait under un Charter
article 51 if the baby's story was not
there the UN would have gone home and
left Kuwait under Iraqi control uh no
the Situation's far more complicated and
the geopolitical perspective in picture
uh was was more than just hey they kill
babies we've got to go in there so
there's a lot of things that happen
behind the scenes especially when it
came to a lot of the secret discussions
between Saddam Hussein and George W bush
and the promise is that the US
government made to Saddam Hussein uh as
of course the United States was working
with Saddam Hussein in order to fight
the Iranians as well so the picture is
far more complicated but for an
emotional standpoint the War was sold to
the American public as going after these
baby killers and it it allowed
emotionally for the United States people
to be like okay I understand this I'm
not going to protest this war this is a
war that we need to fight Trace Ventura
says was Linda raptured or banished to
the shadow realm raptured actually you
may also notice that jam isn't here
either so all the good people have left
it's just us they both uh are at a
monastery now and they pledged uh you
know for virginity and we wish them luck
it was a banishment to the shadow realm
actually uh Lydia inadvertently
activated Luke's trap card and uh it's
entered to the shadow realm the portal
is still open yeah yep we miss you Linda
all right what do we got
Miss Mary says I want to know what Luke
thinks about Tulsi gabbard being on the
Forum of young global leaders created by
Klaus Schwab seems a bit sketch IMO yeah
we talked about that in yesterday's
video now uh I think it's important to
point out that she says that she was put
on there without her permission but
there's other people countering that
saying well if you're implementing
policies that they really like that's
also something that we should keep a
close eye on yeah and like Zuckerberg's
on it yeah and Crenshaw is also on there
and his defenses I didn't do anything
they used my photo without permission
yeah well I think he was saying is that
it's like an editorial thing where it's
it's not like they come to you so I was
featured in uh
in the time 100 nominations so there's
there's 200 people Chosen and then 100
gets elected for the time 100. I was a
nominee no one told me one day I woke up
and Time Magazine said time 100 nominee
Tim pool that's what they're basically
saying that the editorial board would
just says it now her her relationship
with the CFR I think is is definitely
worth looking into
Benjamin Dover says good name by the way
as a truck driver I completely agree
Maryland drivers are probably the worst
I've encountered on the road followed
closely by Delaware Illinois
Massachusetts and New York
what do you think that is
just proximity to DC what do you think
yeah I think it's a little of that I
mean Rhode Island used to have the the
bad reputation too because they didn't
require people to Own auto insurance so
you could get into an accident with a
Rhode Island driver and you might get
yourself into some trouble wow yeah
Utah's had a better reputation for that
for a long time
all right Archimedes says for a super
chat instead of or in addition to States
breaking away from other states what if
States passed legislation to form their
own electoral college for their state
that elects State positions such as
governor
I think uh I don't know good work you
guys want to hear a joke yeah yeah so I
went to a restaurant
and the waitress came up and said can I
get you something to drink
well me being clever I said whatever
floats your boat uh water right when she
came back she brought me an empty cup
except for a piece of paper in it that
had Archimedes law of water displacement
on it
explanations for dinner
it's an old joke from the internet I
heard a long time ago
Archimedes law of water displacement
that was him right is that it I don't
know let's find out yeah whatever floats
your boat I thought I was gonna get a
cup of ice cold water how clever
Kevin Bergman says I'm fourth gen state
of Jefferson our flag is two x's
representing rejection of Salem and SEC
PDX full of first generation frogs who
don't respect the rest of organ
looks confirmed Archimedes principle our
community's principle states that the
upward buoyant force that is exerted on
a body immersed in a fluid whether fully
or partially is equal to the weight of
the fluid that the body displaces and
you know gas is also a fluid interesting
yeah you ever see the video where the
MythBusters float stuff on top of what
is it um sulfur or hydroxide or
something like that sodium hydroxide
what's the gas
sulfur maybe but it's a really dense gas
and visible and they pour it and you and
you it looks like nothing's happening
and then they put like a paper boat and
it's floating on it right over this one
it's a thing that you want to look it up
when you inhale it it makes your voice
really deep yeah yeah that's the one I
remember that sounds pretty cool yeah
DJ Madero says Tim I live in Bend Oregon
we have five different police forces in
the city limits
wow sulfur hexafluoride there you go
sulfur hexafluoride that sounds about
right voisel Satan gas
is that it is because it makes your
voice really deep super low all right
slav Kai Nikki says Ian I've punched a
dog before when I was a kid in order to
protect my little brother who was being
attacked he doesn't like me but I'd do
it again well that's not unreasonable if
a dog's attacking you you have every
right to defend yourself yeah I mean you
can punch a person if they're attacking
you and you're defending yourself you're
supposed to do it right
DJ Montalvo says it if you could get
it's a Gundam on as a guest it would be
great he offers very funny commentary on
cultural issues yeah funny guy well
there you go let's take a look
Richard Adams says if you vote for me
all of your wildest dreams will come
true
vote for you for what
um
no idea dog catcher races are getting
wild now
that's right
all right what do we got here Dan Inez
says I think the comment about keeping
gas down until Republicans take over was
implying that Biden plans to blame the
cost increase on our Republican Congress
yeah but if they win in November it's
not they're not going to be actually in
until January so there's a gap there now
this was about them winning they needed
gas prices to stay low so they could win
let's see
booty sexful says New Hampshire general
election is November 8th just filled out
an absentee ballot I will be out of the
country for reasons but we'll be hand
delivering soon don't forget to vote
it's important what did I read I read
somewhere that New Hampshire New
Hampshire's draft registration rate is
100 percent
and I'm like that sounds kind of odd
and sound like New Hampshire you know no
it doesn't they do have a huge State
Legislature though
yeah you know maybe
all right DD Mega doo doo says Tim's law
if the conversation goes on long enough
Tim will almost certainly use having
chickens as an analogy PS Jimmy Akins
has a full episode on those Pixies from
yesterday he would also make a good
guest oh yeah yeah that um Arthur Conan
Doyle believed in Pixies is that that's
what it was yeah I think so or fairies
in particular fairies yeah great
username by the way you're wrong Fallen
Angel says Tim it would be like the
movie chappie where South Africa uses
robots to augment their Police
Department then a rogue employee
rewrites their code to make the public
afraid of robots that's true yeah
or maybe like District nine when aliens
come and then a guy gets sprayed by
alien Gunk which turns him into an alien
for some reason that I did not
understand it was like it was like a
battery or something well I don't even
know have you seen it yeah in the
theater it was very weird movie yeah I
mean I liked it but I don't understand
why like he was putting a battery
together and then the gunk from the
battery sprays him turning him into an
alien like what is I don't understand I
mean South Africans will know it's
actually a reference to District Six I
just flipped it over to District nine
it's the whole thing I'm not gonna get
into it right now but yeah it's like
about segregation and apartheid and
stuff right yes exactly exactly yep
Tina Collette says black mirror lol last
week I received a package from Amazon I
neither ordered or paid for it it was a
seven pound faux marble toothbrush
holder ugliest thing I have ever seen
what the hell we've had that happen
before but it's rare where we've gotten
a weird package delivered to us we
didn't order and we just like we don't
accept it I don't know what this is yeah
but it was like I can't remember what it
was we've gotten weird stuff like books
I'm just like I don't know what this is
weird yeah but uh we know for a fact
that it was like somehow you know you
know what it is I think recently we
ordered something and they gave us the
wrong thing so someone in the warehouse
probably put the wrong thing in the box
and gave it to us true yeah
let's grab one more what do we got Steve
Smith says all right hear me out if LA
and New Jersey can have two teams why
can't Chicago have two teams at least
one in the AFC they can actually root
for
I don't know sure I guess that'd be cool
all right my friends
smash that like button if you haven't
already become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up for you at 11 PM you don't
want to miss it share the video be the
notification you want to see in the
world because unfortunately we are being
censored you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
you want to shout anything out Jim
absolutely I think everybody needs to
not vote if they're going to vote the
wrong way but I'll leave it up to you
what the wrong way is hey that's good
you've got social media or anything or a
website yeah definitely you can follow
me at Jim antel which is not Mickey
Mantle but it's
j-i-m-a-n-t-l-e on twitter.com well it
lasts right on that's true while we
still have some kind of voice thank you
so much for coming on Jen appreciate you
uh my YouTube channel is we are changed
today's video highlights the story of
Johnny Hurley a big member of we are
change Colorado learn about him his
story I think is very important a lot of
people need to hear about this uh the
shirt I'm wearing we are selling it all
the profits are going to the Johnny
Hurley Foundation youtube.com forward
slash we are change thanks for having me
oh death definitely definitely Luke I'm
glad to have hosted you tonight uh bye
everyone Ian Crossing hey catch me at
Ian crossland.net or just follow me on
social media anywhere Jim it's great to
see you man nice to be here and Tim you
weren't wrong according to USA Today
from 2019 a registration Vader varied
from this is a Selective Service 100 in
New Hampshire sure to 63 in North Dakota
wow and just 51 in District I can't
confirm if that's true but you probably
did read it
all right yeah thanks guys you guys can
follow me at surge.com uh I do read the
chat comments I do respond it is
actually me in the chat it's at
surge.com so I'll see you guys there
tonight for as long as I can hang out
right on we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys